Going live.
I'm live now.
And I tweeted too.
Guys, did you hear that?
She's live now.
Yeah, that's the intro.
I'm going live now.
I'm going in.
Live but not alive.
I'm alive and I'm live.
You are not alive.
Don't lie.
No, no, when I joined, I was like, I can call now.
And then I was like, hey.
And then she was like.
No, you didn't even say anything.
I was just like, oh, wait, I can't.
No, I did.
I was like, hey.
And then you were like, wait, I think I should change
something at this screen.
And I was like, no, that's just me.
I was like, I can't hear you.
Oh, are you muted?
What's happening?
And then I was like, oh wait, give me a, oh, wait, give me a
sec.
My coffee's coming.
I'll be right back.
I have no reception in this room.
Give me a sec.
Wait, did you get your coffee?
Oh?
Wait.
Wait, wait.
I thought she got her coffee.
Wait, is she just now getting her coffee?
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Fears to Fathom.
I don't know if Doki's ever played in.
of these games before all right oh i'm back hi sorry i have
to i have to like call my phone to let in but i've no risk
my reception in this room is so bad i have to get out of the
room to accept the call oh my god okay oh yeah so basically
when i i was not alive when i first took when i called mint
she thought it was discord but i was it was just you not
okay it was just me i was not okay how was korea it was fun
it was fun i did i guys it was i you can't get anything out
of mint because like i told her i was like i can't say
anything she said nothing to me for real though yeah yeah
yeah she was like what are you doing korea and i was like i
can't say anything or they're gonna get me they're gonna get
i yeah because i was going to the ace combat thing and then
i asked her what she was doing yeah like oh you're gonna
have to wait next week i was like oh no they're gonna get
her too yes we had our secret journeys we had our little
secrets yeah um but i'm i'm just so fucked up right now like
I came back I didn't like the thing is like I came back
usually you need like several days to acclimate back to your
back to your time zone yeah but like I like I when I came
back I went instantly to sleep and it was already like
nighttime so then I was like it should be fine I think I
should be fine usually no right no no it was not and then
the day two and then day two I couldn't sleep like even
though I like had a like the like I slept at an NA time when
at the moment I came back on day two I literally went to
sleep at 9 a.m.
because I couldn't sleep at all and then and then it like
and then yesterday I tried it again I got it back it was
like 9 a.m.
the next two days and then yesterday I got it back again and
then and then I'm so fucking tired I am so tired right now
um it's so bad it's so bad I thought I, I, I thought, and I
went straight back to work too.
So it was just like, my body is like self-destructing right
now.
You know what it sounds like?
You're getting old.
No, no, no.
No.
No, that can't be.
That, that can't be.
I hope, I hope, uh, since you're moving, right?
Yeah.
Since you're moving, I hope they approve your visa the
moment.
you move
yeah that would be really funny wouldn't it haha would have
they approved my visa to Japan the day that I move yeah
you know what you can't you unpack everything everything has
been unpacked and then you get the email I hope you can't
curse me with that because I've already thought about it
it's okay I'm double I'm doubling it I'm doubling it and
giving it to the next person I mean they did say that last I
heard they did say it might get approved at the end of June
and um that's when all my stuff arrives for me to unpack
I hope it's like beginning of July because then at that time
you'd be unpacking all the stuff that arise.
Yeah, because I'd be like, wow, my new cafe is so great!
Yay!
And then...
And then you gotta do it all over again.
I don't know, I don't think I'll do it, though.
I think I've tried to move to Japan.
I've like, back in 2020, I got a job in Japan, and then I
was... I remember that, yeah.
Yeah, and I was gonna go, and they ghosted me.
And then I got another job and they said, oh yeah, we'll
give you a visa for Japan.
And then they only started doing that after I left.
You were asking too.
Yeah, because you were like, Renee, what's the update?
And it wasn't even for you too.
I know.
Yeah, because you were asking for it.
And then when they finally started the process, it wasn't
even for you.
No.
I remember too because I was just like oh I got this other
job in Japan like I could go for it and but I because I
really want to move over there so would you be able to do
that because I'm I'm turning down another job for your job
they were like yeah we could do that yeah and then like and
then then you waited and then you're like hey remember then
I asked about that visa thing and then they're like oh yeah
we're trying to work on it and then and then you find out it
wasn't even for you yeah and now it's for everybody else
it's okay now it's fine now you can't yes it's okay your
visa is gonna get approved your visa is gonna get approved
the moment you unpack i i feel it oh thank you thank you for
my good luck charm.
I know, I hope it happens the exact moment you put down your
last item too.
Oh yeah, I check, I'm like, oh, I got an email.
The monkey paw girl.
I'm the dokey paw girl.
The dokey paw.
I'm imagining underneath your glove, it's like all shriveled
and gross.
Yeah, yeah, all shriveled.
I was like,
just disgustingly curls and then like even when you use up
all the fingers it just resets itself oh that's what wait
what happens when you use up the monkey paw it's just it
ends oh that's it like you it's like you use up all the
wishes basically until all the paws are curled out oh but
mine just resets yeah yours is like yours goes like hey high
five then it starts all over again It's like, don't leave me
hanging.
No, it's like, it's like, it's an open palm first.
And then when it fully curls, it's like, hey, bro fist.
And then when you fist it, you're like, yeah.
Yeah.
High five, down low.
No, it goes, yeah.
It goes, bro fist.
And like, when you know how, like, people, like, pull that
whole back and, like, do these push?
It just opens up.
Alright, anyway, this is a gaming stream.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I'm chibi.
I'm a dokey chibi right now because I want to feel included.
Oh, yeah.
Because, yeah.
I'm chibi because for some reason, when I click into the
game, it starts making me lag a little bit.
moving so yeah and then I didn't want to feel left out so I
was like hey I want to be achieving too also cuz she didn't
want to join my collab room cuz she's a
Is that a threat?
Mitt, I hope you grow old.
Oh no!
I'm young and beautiful forever, old person.
No matter what, you'll always be older than me.
How?
You literally passed my age, probably.
You, no, I know.
I know, no matter what.
I know.
You don't know anything.
You know nothing, Doki Bird.
You know nothing.
What the fuck do you mean?
Whenever you and Matara stream together, you have, like, the
wavelengths.
The wavelengths?
Okay, do not put me on the same level of her.
She's way beyond.
You two send each other, you're like, oh, you know, like,
like same hat, same hat.
You two, the moment you two together, you're like, same hag,
same hat.
This is offensive.
Do not put me on the same level as her.
I'm getting my coffee.
I don't think you need it.
Why did I, why did I ask Doki to play this?
with me.
Remember, Dukia's graying hair.
I know, I've seen it.
I've seen the gray strands in her hair.
Yeah, you know what?
Yeah, some of my chat, hack-to-hack communication.
Okay.
Yeah, that's why you've been getting along with Matara so
well recently, too, huh?
No, I'm like, I'm like her at Proje.
Proje?
I'm like an apprentice.
We don't need more than one of her, but like...
I'm like the apprentice.
She's teaching me the ways.
Of what, hag though?
To make her feel young again, you know?
Oh, are you teaching her like six, seven?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm teaching her like how the zoomers speak and then she's
teaching me hag speak so I can communicate with you better.
What have you learned?
okay use your teachings time to go what i learned i became
more alcoholic in korea that's what i learned power of soju
shall we yeah shall we play we shall we shall play now what
is this game i yeah have you ever played a fears of fathom
before nope okay they're like nope you they're like people
like send in their true stories asterisk and they make a
video game out of them with artistic liberties it's like
they took some stories off of reddit and then yeah see at
the bottom it says you have a story send it but this is
their first multiplayer we should send a story over we
should we should write something on stream and then send it
over my name is midfanto yeah we could be in the game he
would have to make models oh no we could be like i'm haunted
by a very annoying ghost wait this is the hack to get into
the game i think oh gosh i'm really starting to lag what's
wrong with me oh no only when i click out of that click into
the game i start lagging this is based on a true story it is
right now this is the story wait if i click connect okay i'm
gonna invite you i haven't booted the game up oh my god
what's wrong oh it says it's only about two hours okay good
because i think i'm gonna be up packing until like 4 a.m
again i had because it's like you're literally moving your
uh everything yeah i've been up until like 4 a.m every night
holy shit That's crazy.
I'm excited.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
The dev literally says you are playing the first episode,
but I'm too tired to make another multiplayer game.
What?
I'm waiting for my friend to join.
I don't think she's going to join guys.
Is it...
I like how these just sayings are graphics.
It's like NASA computer and...
you know toaster and then not toaster did you I'm on toaster
to make sure to put toaster I'm on toaster I just gotta be I
just gotta be sure you know I got three just got you know
we're on toaster PC you all right yeah can you actually
teach me stuff on Steam sure so what you need to do is you
go to friends and chat and then you click on my name I
already invited you.
Did you not get it?
No, because you did not do it correctly.
I did.
But it's okay.
I'm here now to help you.
I'm sending invite.
I'm looking for a survival.
Invite, invite, friend.
Invite, friend.
You did not.
There's no way.
I said there's no notification.
I've sent it like five times.
I can watch you.
You could watch me.
Yeah.
Wait, it doesn't show up though.
I invited.
Can you see that me inviting?
you to watch.
Oh, I invited you to watch.
Invite.
What am I doing?
Where did you go?
Wait, you disappeared.
What?
You disappeared on the friends list.
Oh, there you are.
You're back in VTube Studio.
Oh, my game just crashed, I think.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, Doki, why did you crash my game?
Oh, yeah, I crashed your game.
I'm sending in the waves.
I'm sending in...
Why?
Why did you crash my game?
Wait, actually, hold on.
My computer might be dying.
For real?
Why?
How is it dying?
It won't let me click on VTube Studio.
That's fine.
I'm going back to open the game.
Fierce of fandom.
Just be a PNG.
Why are we not inviting each other?
Oh, it crashed again.
Wait.
What's happening?
Oh, yeah.
The moment I put up the game, it's okay.
hoarding all the bandwidth that's why if you have the yeah
guys she's moving over here that's where she's going what
into your house already here yeah to my to my one bedroom
apartment don't say that people will think things you can
yeah that you're gonna sleep on the floor wait the game is
actually crashing though wait what's happening Maybe at the
reset your...
I like how when I booted the game, your game started
crashing.
I know.
I've been sitting on it for like an hour.
Wait, what the hell?
Play?
You have to...
I just keep booting up.
Mint Fantome is now playing Fears.
Fears to Fathom.
Scratch Creek.
Oh, it opened.
It opened.
Alright.
That sent me the invite.
I'm doing it.
Did you get it?
Oh, now, yeah, I got it this time.
Oh, yeah, let's go!
I'm booting it.
Yeah!
All right, I'm booting you.
I'm not...
I'm lowering your thingy.
Stop talking.
Okay.
I'm lowering it.
I'm putting 154 here, so I remember.
Because in case we get a call again, we're like, why can't I
hear her?
What?
Oh, you're so right.
Wait, you're so right.
What's 154 mean?
That's your Discord thing.
my discord oh wait that's yeah that's like you know how when
you do the muting thing oh you put me at like 154.
yeah i put you at 154.
why am i so quiet all the time i don't fucking know i
all right chat how's i don't even know my sound gas alive
i'm not alive my audio team's not alive oh you're so loud
yeah i'm tired yeah I got you there.
Is audio team alive?
I've been worried, but I think we're cronchy, yeah.
Are we cronchy?
Well, it's immersive.
Yeah, it's immersive game.
It's called immersion because we're in the VHS right now.
Okay, I'm starting a new game.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No.
Wait.
Oh, you...
Dang it.
You have to select it, too.
Wait.
Ah, that's right.
Hurry up.
You think you're so clever.
Guys, I can't.
I'm getting rid of chat.
I can't keep refreshing it.
Oh, my God.
Is this YouTube doing that to you recently?
Guys, if you want...
No, wait, what?
Like, it keeps freezing on your stream.
Oh, it's...
I think it did that one time, but I think it's just because
like my PC was sort of low-key dying No, it it does it it
like every stream for me multiple times I have no idea even
on your actual PC.
Yeah on my actual.
Yeah, that's weird.
I only have that happen one time Do you use browser like OBS
for your chat?
No, do you?
Oh, I do.
I think I'm gonna change it.
Oh, I think it's that I just all I do is, you know, like
grab your YouTube chat and I just open it because it can
open as its own window and i just do that and then drag it
to my third monitor wait no i mean like on your stream no if
you wait yeah when you go to your stream and then there's
you there's the chat there you can just open it to a new
browser no i i have wait because you're talking about the
obs integrated chat right like i browser source it and i
copy the link mean on your stream it's dying yeah yeah yeah
yourself um it has happened to me sometimes but i don't know
what's the cause for sometimes it's okay and sometimes i
have to refresh it yeah it's so i think it could be the code
too because youtube changed their coding i did i fucked up
my css yeah so i think like i think it could be a code
that's just like lagging it annoying because yeah all right
i'm in okay oh i mean am i am i marcus wait who there was
the other person marcus i'm tessa oh no i'm tessa you're
marcus i'll be marcus i'll be marcus i'm ready to i guess
i'll i'll die first i guess why it's always in the horror
films it's like a trove i'm the trove wait so i'm the sexy
virgin girl that lives lives yeah Yeah, yeah, you want to
be...
You want to...
Oh, she's gone, you guys.
I want to be...
If you want to be my lover, you gotta get with her, my
friend.
Oh, fears to fathom together!
This is fun.
This is fun, guys.
Scratch Creek.
You scratch my creek.
I scratch yours.
She's already dead.
Sorry about the lag.
Try not to talk about it.
I'm sent...
April 30th.
You know what, they did.
this today?
I'm not usually one to write for the internet.
Don't get me wrong, I do write, but these might be the first
few words the world actually reads.
For context, I'm a huge fan of indie horror games.
When I played one of your games, I couldn't help but notice
weird similarities to something that happened to us, me and
my boyfriend, Marcus.
Don't keep her just my boyfriend.
I've also convinced him to write, so please be on the
lookout for his email as well.
Wait, is she reading something different?
Wait, that's crazy.
From the age of 18, I automatically became independent.
I think that's how that works, no?
I moved into an apartment that my dad inherited from his
grandmother and moved in with the boy of my dreams.
I think I was only 20 or so at the time when Marcus finally
got his first real job offer.
The only catch was, it was in a different state.
Knowing how much that job meant to him at the time, I was
instantly determined to move out with him in support.
Marcus had his uncle's old car and we had rented a moving
trailer moving cause this is is this is this a moving
simulator i think i might go insane don't do this to me
hello hello hello
shut up for god thank you guys for the super chats thank you
hello oh i think i see her That's got to be her.
Donkey!
That's got...
Wow, so...
What?
What, hello?
Oh.
Hey.
Wait, you talk?
You know what this... It showed me that you're a very slow
reader.
What do you mean?
You had a different story than me.
Sorry, I get into the mood.
I create the atmosphere.
Yeah, you know, it says on my side it was like, your player
two is still reading after I'm done.
They're like talking.
Why are you paused?
I know.
Why are they so muffled talking?
It's like, it's not even a word.
Wow, it's a fence.
This fence is, like, muffling us.
It might be easier to...
Here, I'm going to walk this way.
Let me go this way.
Here we go.
Do you know that you're, like, literally...
Throw my fucking hose at you.
Hold on, I got to text my dad.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I hope they get you.
How do I text my dad?
Is that not enter?
I hope the ghost...
How do I text my dad?
What is this?
Oh my god, I can hear you better at this angle.
What is that sound?
Oh, it's locked.
I can't do anything.
You mean, it's this door?
Stranger.
Stranger danger.
Oh, Tab.
You guys are so smart.
Love you, daddy.
Coming over in 15, kiddo.
Hey, random question.
Would it be a huge deal if we left tomorrow morning instead
of tonight?
Yes, we were packing up the last couple of boxes.
If you don't, if you're gonna read your text, I'm gonna read
my text to right next to you.
Tell her I said hi back.
I think she's stupid, you guys.
Yes, actually.
The painting crew is coming first thing tomorrow, since you
said you'd be out by tonight.
I already told Marcus everything needs to be cleared.
All right, we'll get moving then.
I'm still on track and we're aiming to head out the tent.
Let me know if you need anything on our end.
The painting crew is coming first thing tomorrow.
We need to clear it.
should load but you'll get a feel for the room you'll be
mostly shadowing decks your first week to get you up to
speed on our mastering systems let's start with the couch
and then work our way to the back all right let's start with
the couch wait how are you here i came outside oh okay you
want me to read you my text oh i'm gonna read mine look at
your drive is not that long but unload in the morning proud
of you kiddo safe travels once you hit the road home late
say sorry Stop yelling at me!
Zooming you to my lady, beef, a jerk.
Why did I text you beef jerky?
Did you see that?
Wait, oh, I saw beef jerky.
Wait, you just searched.
Yeah, I can see you.
Wait, I'm gonna move my, I'm gonna move myself so people can
see the text.
I'll move myself too.
Yeah.
I'll be, give us a sec so we can have- your text guys guys i
have important text message that i have to answer beef jerky
beef jerky beef jerky where's my beef jerky jerky one second
let me move you two where you at boo will you be home late
today sorry boo i made you pie wrapping this up and zoom
into you my lady You calling me your lady?
Damn!
You wanted to play this game.
Wait, what's the cow?
I have zero cows per second.
Wait, is this like cookie?
Oh my god, it's cookie clipper.
Wait, what are you doing?
I'm getting cows.
We can't afford cows.
You don't see...
Oh, to be fair, back then, houses were cheaper.
We can't text dad, my dad at work.
Hey, dad.
I have one cow per second.
How many do you have?
Oh, I can't.
I can't only.
Oh, I see it.
Wait.
What number are you at?
400.
I see the game.
I'm at 167 cows now.
I'm at a thousand cows.
I don't believe you.
Guys, shit is.
believe me i would i don't believe because you're i mean
you're not spending your cows i i 100 have you i'm not
spending your cows i'm getting 44 cows per click oh yeah
yeah wait there's more oh my god there's more there's more
cows oh oh cow farm i have a farm i have a first before you
did.
I'm about to get whatever the 9,000 thing is.
Oh, yeah, me too.
Hey, remember when they said this game was two hours?
Yeah.
I was just thinking that.
Why would they say that?
Why would they lie?
I think this game is not just two hours.
What if the actual gameplay is like 20 minutes and then
everybody spends it on...
I have a hundred per click now.
I have 200 per second.
Me too.
Um, okay.
Me too times infinity.
Times infinity?
Yeah.
How many cows per click do you get?
Uh, I have like a thousand cows per click.
I have almost 3,000.
This is pathetic.
I have almost 5,000.
That's a lie.
It's not a lie.
Actually, I almost have 9,000.
Oh my gosh, I got the cow factory.
Holy hell.
Oh my gosh, I'm swimming in cows.
Oh my god, they can't stop moving.
I can't stop moving.
Holy cow, there's, oh my god.
Holy cow, there's so many cows.
Yeah.
Plus 5,000 per second.
I'm going to get to the 25 million.
Oh, I'm going to get there first.
Oh, wait.
Wait, there's 15 million.
Oh, my God.
There's 30 million.
Yeah.
You can get 30 million points.
It goes crazy.
Hold on.
All right.
I'm almost there.
I'm going to increase.
Move.
more moon more moon more more moon moon moon more refer
factor just i got the emperor clicker i got the emperor
clicker oh you got two million yeah i'm about to reach it
again holy cow oh my god that's so many cows there's so many
cows so much power i don't have auto clicker on this damn
computer wait can you just download it right now i guess i
could if i wanted to i'm lazy you're 11k second how many
factories do you have i have 47 clicks per second or 47 000.
how many cows do you have per second i have 10 000 i have 40
000 what's what are you doing how many what do you mean
i'm clicking cows 50.
50.
Alright.
Now I have Emperor Clicker.
Okay, good job.
Keep going.
I did it.
The rich only gets richer.
And you spend cows to make cows.
You're so right.
Yeah, you have to spend cows to make cows, exactly.
I wonder if I get to a hundred of them each.
I'll do another Emperor Clicker.
Yeah, me too.
I have five of them.
Actually, I have six.
Yep, five emperor clickers?
I have seven.
Now I have eight.
Oh my god!
She's unpalable.
I love cow clicker!
Unstoppable!
They should have advertised this, honestly, to get more
people.
This should be its very own game.
I got the cow pyramid.
You got the cow pyramid, Rory.
right now i'm about this is a different timeline where
instead of cats it's cows i'm making 245 000 cows per second
oh my god i'm gonna get to the 30 million wait what's the
top holy wait do you actually see how far this goes how far
does this go oh my god i don't even know what kind of number
that is there's so many zeros what kind of number is that
There's so many zeros!
Do you think like we're gonna dive to the killer or?
Did you think in the story they're like, Wow, we were about
to get killed.
We just had a competitive little cow clicking competition.
Yeah, well we had a competitive cow clicking game that me
and my girlfriend will play all the time.
Wait, there's the Pope clicker.
Yeah, I have one.
A Pope is here.
oh just one the pope the pope is a cow everything is cow
everything is cow it's like lizard people but it's cow
people yeah they actually the the cow people spread the
lizard people meme or so that oh so they won't know yeah
they would never guess cow people yeah yeah it's like
propaganda like anti-propaganda against lizards yeah maybe
there's lizard people and cow people but the like the the
cow people is like the illuminati for the lizard people oh
man oh the lizard people think they're like oh my gosh don't
talk don't even get us started about the cow people oh
you're just like yeah and you're like oh you think we run
the government yeah the cow people are this run the secret
secret government of the lizard people wait i'm about to get
i'm about to get whatever's under pope cow temple oh i
reached a heart oh my god I got an achievement for a hundred
million.
What'd you get?
The cow temple?
Oh my god, I got it too!
Yeah!
Oh my god, look at all these cows!
Guys, we're...
Our cowspiracy, yes!
Cowspiracy!
That's why we have global warming.
Do you know, like, cows contribute to global warming?
Because they fart too much.
Yeah, they fart a lot.
Oh, but cows are so cute!
I can't be mad at them.
They can cause a little global warming.
as a treat.
Just a little bit, you know?
Yeah.
I wonder if there's PvP in this game.
I wonder if there's a leaderboard.
There's a leaderboard?
I wonder if there is.
They should add a leaderboard.
Wait, is the dev here?
We'd be at the top?
Dev, please, put us at the top of the leaderboard.
Can you put a leaderboard?
Give us a cameo.
Yeah, me first, then Doki Bird.
Yeah, no, no.
We'll send you a story.
Put us in.
I need more I need more cows I'm making almost a million
cows per second though a million cows I'm gonna have 625,000
cows per second I don't know man you gotta up your cow game
I'm old McMinto had a farm E-I-E-I-O had a farm E-I-E-I-O
it's just cows too on this far she had many cows E-I-I-O
Wait, what's the 175?
God clicker.
I'm my God clicker.
I'm gonna grab another cow tempo.
How many?
Wait, you only have one?
I have three right now.
Oh, dang.
It's more than me, actually.
I need more cows.
I like how the music sometimes gets creepy, but it's...
We're just totally cowing it up.
This is the best Zatsu game ever.
Oh my god.
I know.
Have you ever been to a farm?
Yeah.
Have you?
No.
And there's...
Like, I mean, petting zoos.
I don't think that counts, though.
No, I've been to real farms.
Well, I think.
I don't know.
You ever seen a real cow?
Yeah.
There's, like, cow therapy.
Because cows are...
Is cow therapy?
Yeah.
Yeah, you like go and you cuddle with cows.
Oh, wait, that's cute.
I kind of want to do it.
I need therapy and cows.
Maybe.
I wonder if it's cheaper than dog therapy.
Oh.
You know, like during like exam season at universities, you
just send in the dogs.
Wait, they do that?
Yeah.
My school used to do that.
It was like, or I mean, they still do during like, it's like
exam week and then like finals week.
And then they have like a special area.
uh where people like kids can cuddle the dogs before they
have a nervous breakdown over their exams but you have to
pay for it there's mine for free oh okay then why why would
it be why would it be more expensive it's free oh no that's
what i'm saying when you think cow therapy is free or not oh
i don't think so therapy is not free you have to pay someone
to listen to you We live in a society.
You see that video of the horse that goes around, plays a
piano?
Oh, yeah, he's really good.
He's in the hospital.
Yeah, he's so good.
I want his autograph.
Yeah, me too.
My finger's starting to hurt.
He's got a fever and the only prescription is more cow.
More cow, more cow.
So I'm going to go to the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
Yeah.
I'm at God Clicker now.
Yeah, I have five of them.
You have five of the God Clicker?
Now I have to get five of the god clickers.
The next one is a pretty big jump, though, so I haven't
gotten to the next one.
I think just adding more god clickers the way to go.
Me too.
Oh, man.
It's starting to get really big jumps right here.
Guys, will we make it?
Will we make it?
I'm so behind.
Well, she was playing this game in her bathroom earlier
while I was locked out of the house.
I literally discovered it right in front of you.
You were reading text!
What are you talking about?
Actually, wait.
I was trying to read text from my dad because I actually
wanted to know if my dad's safe.
Wait, do you think it'll work in the background?
What do you mean?
Oh my god, you just lagged there.
No, do you think it'll work?
Like the, do you think the clicker will work in the
background?
The auto-clicker?
Yeah, because I get a million cows per second, yeah.
Try it right now.
Okay, hold on.
350, wait, how do I exit out of this?
Okay, 364, 355.
Okay.
I'm giving it a couple seconds.
We stopped at 365, guys.
365.
All right.
No, it doesn't go in the background.
It doesn't go in the background.
You have to stay.
You'll have, you know what would have been funny if you,
like, turn off your phone and it resets your progress.
I was waiting for that.
That's why I was like, you go first.
Oh, okay.
No, I had trust in my cows.
They would come back always.
Okay, I have nine god clickers now.
Me too.
Oh yeah?
Yeah.
I have ten.
Me too.
Oh yeah, I have eleven.
Uh, one second.
Me too.
She was buffering?
Sorry, I lagged, I lagged, I lagged.
I lagged, I lagged.
More.
I'm at 14 now.
How many cows per second do you make?
A million cows.
A million, 25,429.
Only a million.
Rich only gets richer.
Someone should just eat the rich.
Eat the rich.
Eat the cows that are making them rich.
I'm almost at 3 million cows per second.
Now I'm at 3 million cows per second.
Cows.
That is more than 2 million.
It just processed in my head how many we have to get for the
next year.
I know.
Like, I need, like, two million from where I'm at.
It's, or, like, it's crazy.
My finger hurts.
Coward.
Week.
No, I'm still going.
I'm still going.
Why don't you take a little break, huh?
No, I've got to be on two times always.
Two times always.
Wait.
I just hit the first...
I hit one.
A billion.
Whatever that number is.
I can't.
There's too many.
There's too many numbers.
Oh, you just hit one.
Guys, it's not fears to fathom.
It's fears to cow them.
Oh, are you almost at the two?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, I'm at almost at there.
Oh, my computer is breaking down.
This is crazy.
There's too many kids.
I'm getting too many cows.
The cow power plant.
Oh, I'm almost there.
I didn't want to.
I was a fool.
I should have.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just get it.
You know, you didn't want to be on the top for too long, you
know?
You want to have an actual competition.
Yeah, but I'm still making 3 million more per second.
Even the...
Evening up the playing field.
How many god clickers do you have?
Wait, what's the power plant give you?
It gives me like 10.
Oh, I got it.
100,000.
Per second.
Oh, shoot!
Wow!
I'm at 18!
Whoa!
God.
Oh, yeah?
Guess who just built her second power plant.
Dang, you're going fast.
Yeah.
My finger.
It's like they're used to cow farts to power it.
Oh.
It's like it's a special type of gas.
They learn to energize the farts.
Hold on.
I'm going to keep getting more.
Oh, oops.
That's fine.
21 is fine.
I need to get another power plant, too.
I'm going to.
I got some more God clickers.
I'm investing big.
Yeah, I'm about to.
I'm about to.
Methane power.
My methane power plant.
I'm almost there though.
I think we should probably know.
I'm almost there.
Oh my god, the next step is 20 billion.
Yeah, it's kind of ridiculous.
How far?
Do you think we'll make it?
I don't think we'll make it.
It's only up from here, baby.
Second power plant.
Let's go.
Oof.
How many god clickers do you have?
Such child's play.
How many god...
How many... I have...
Oh yeah, but how many power plants do you have though?
How many god clickers do you have?
You know one...
You know like one power plant equals a hundred god clickers.
Yeah, but you still gotta click.
You still gotta click.
You still gotta click!
You always have to click.
down to clicking it always comes down to clicking
competitive clicking what's your apm huh my cow pm 48
billion whatever this number is i don't know i don't know
man okay 63 the new esport i'm surprised there's no esports
about clicking honestly it could be huge you can start it
you can be the change in the world yeah yes i could start
the esport org
do i like go for the 20 i think i go for the good i think i
will all right i have five power plants 25 god clickers
seven power plants and i'm eight now i've invested in
another power plant you have eight wait you just oh you just
had seven that's right i was like how did you
I'll go to 10.
I have one per continent.
One per continent.
How many god clickers do you have?
Doesn't matter.
I have eight cow power plants now.
Okay, I'm right behind you.
I'm right behind you, man.
You gotta get your clicks up.
All right.
I got another one just now.
I just built another one at your home next door to your
house.
What, my power plant?
Yeah.
Yeah, I built one next to your power plant, too.
another one okay i built another one again just now i built
another one too despite you i just built one i just built
one oh yeah yeah yeah wait we're not gonna get one more
again don't you gotta get eye on the prize we gotta get to
the 20.
oh yeah i just built another one what are you gonna do how
many do you have how many do you have um would you want to
know okay fine keep your secrets just look out the window i
have just as many as you i have just as many as you oh yeah
yeah who just got the 20 million the clicker if you did have
just as many as me you would have gotten it i'm halfway
there i'm halfway there you don't know you don't know you
don't know shit you don't know you don't know shit you don't
know shit you don't know shit you don't know shit you don't
know you don't know you don't know you have no idea even in
my tax bracket.
You have no idea.
Go talk with the little kids.
Go to the millionaire club.
You, I'm spending, I'm spending big.
You have no idea.
The rich keep getting rich.
Eat the cows.
Eat the cow rich.
The rich just get richer.
Wait, oh my gosh.
My clicks are going crazy right now guys oh my god i just
have two i just got two of the clicker what does it give you
it gives me like 200 2 million i can't there's too many
zeros there's 20 zeros wait i'm about to get it i'm about to
get it i like the music it makes me feel stupid oh dang whoa
so many clicks okay god clicker is dead everybody oh i just
realized that the next drop is 80 billion I know.
That's like easy.
That's easy.
I'm more worried from 80 to 300.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
I feel like the 80 would give us a lot, though.
I think maybe.
Maybe.
Yeah.
A real Nepo cow.
Oh, my God.
It gives you so much.
Need more of this.
More.
Wait.
Are you downloading an auto-clicker?
I don't know.
I'm talking to my chat.
What are you talking about?
Press the checker PC.
What is cheating if it's not using my resources?
In the 90s?
You're breaking immersion.
A real gamer would use her fingers.
No, you wouldn't.
All right, watch this, guys.
Watch this.
She has macros on.
Wow, just when I pressed her back, cracked it.
This is how the rich get richer, baby.
Work harder, not, I mean, smarter, not harder.
Are you even trying, Doki?
What the hell?
If you're not cheating, then you're not trying.
I'm not getting carpal tunnel over this.
Yes, more, more, more.
Okay, I'll do one more clicker.
Guys, this might crash my computer.
We'll see.
Joki?
Yeah, are you actually doing it?
Are you actually getting auto-clicker?
Yeah, I'm like sipping my coffee right now.
You're...
saying this is what i do on cookie clicker too oh my god you
cheat in cookie clicker no there's actually an achievement
for cheating oh wait really yeah it's like actually hacking
it oh my god yeah the guys this is the task run what are you
talking about
this quantity is Hmm.
Wait, are you at the 80 yet?
Uh, no, I'm almost there.
Oh my god.
How many clickers do you have?
Auto clickers?
Oh, clickers I only have four.
Wait, how many auto clickers do you have?
Wait a minute.
Wouldn't you like to know?
Yeah.
Why did you have, I was there a plural by that.
What did you, you could never handle this power.
She's min-maxing right now.
Are you ready for the 80 million?
Cow earth.
No, I'm not.
Cow earth?
Cow earth.
Okay, that's it.
Give me that file.
Give me that.
send that file over
look it's like they're like toward the front you know
they're all you can't if they're all doping then it's then
it's fair what are you at what are you at everyone does it
what are you at uh i'm still not i'm at 33 million right now
oh dang we got equalized to how many clickers do you have um
i was playing with integrity but obviously i only made a
fool of myself oh when have you ever if you could if you
could you would i i was evening the playing field for myself
i was giving it even evening it for myself apparently
integrity doesn't pay the bills uh yeah but i'm I'm so chill
right now.
Don't you want to see the end of the cow game?
Chat, the only way...
Send me the files.
Okay.
At least the clicker files.
Here.
Uh.
Here you go.
Wait, well, let me send an EXE.
Does this think I'm sending you a virus?
Okay, yeah.
that's yeah my Minecraft build real quick I'm gonna click it
and then they're like it's actually ransomware it's actually
ransomware alright hey guys Mint sent me a Minecraft file
that we should check out her world guys let me it looks so
fucking fake it does it does so bad that's the Just as
onClicker.exe.
It literally is just that.
Windows protected your PC.
But run an unrecognized app from starting.
Run it anyway.
Just do it anyway.
Trust.
Trust me.
How do I do this?
Let's see.
One millisecond.
Yeah, that's what I do.
Pick location.
No, don't do the pick location.
Just do the hot click, like the...
Just click.
Click F6 to start it.
It's easier.
F6 to start?
Yeah.
Oh, thanks for the fit together!
Thank you.
Where is it clicking, though?
You just hover your mouse over where you need to click it,
and then it'll go.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, so I'm just over top the cow.
Wait, how do...
I just click start, but it stops.
Oh, maybe you got the bad version.
You sent me this version.
version don't get it oh my god what the fuck what are you
doing it must have been on oh no no okay no oh my god is it
working yeah it's it's working oh my god i know it's it's
like game changer right no wonder I get it now I get why
they I'll get why people dope yeah
I'm wondering if I should get more clickers though hmm to up
my click I'm just I'm just doing cow I'm just doing cow
earth power it's we're going to the moon guys I don't know
if cow earth I mean cow earth is good but like it's only per
second I feel like I'm making all my cows 9.001 millisecond,
or is it just one?
I don't know.
Let's try it.
Does it work?
0.0...
Oh, no.
You can only type a number.
It's a no.
Only one millisecond.
That's right.
I distracted her.
She had to type 1.
0.1.
Oh, why do I have a watermelon all of a sudden?
Wait.
I'm holding a watermelon.
I don't know why.
What's going on?
I think I was hungry.
I instinctively pulled it.
Why do I have a watermelon?
Guys, help.
Oh my gosh, I'm being hacked for real.
It's an autoclicker.exe.
Who would have thought that would have done that?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know.
Do I go for the 300?
It's going to take forever, you guys.
Should we play the game?
No, unless you have more cowherds.
Someone's a coward.
I'm not.
How many cowherds do you have?
Oh, yeah.
I said it's a person that's been using an auto clicker since
the beginning.
Not even from the beginning.
Shut up.
You wish.
I would be like crazy ahead of you.
Yeah.
At the moment I was ahead, you brought out, you brought out
the drugs.
I'm a sore loser.
You just couldn't stand the fact that I was better than you
at clicking things.
Yeah.
No, I felt it.
I felt, you know, it's not even.
It's literally working smarter.
You're like, this is my game.
I'm not letting Tokey Bird win this one.
Yeah, pretty much.
She doesn't even play clicker games.
I open cookie clicker twice a year.
And so therefore, I deserve this win.
The real horror is a phone game addiction.
At least it's not a flappy clone.
A flappy bird clone.
How many cowherbs do you have?
four yeah four wait we're on the same page all right yeah
look at that look at that look at that we're practically
equal now to each other we are yeah she's gonna proceed to
download a second auto clicker yeah clicking is for peasants
I can hire people for my I'm too big it's too big she
literally got she literally got an A to do her clicking for
her now.
The AI is taking the clicking jobs.
Yeah, they're taking our jobs.
Not even clicking is safe now.
I think I'm gonna go for the 300.
I was already going for it.
Alright, let's go.
I never stopped.
I don't give up.
I don't give up either.
Never back down.
Never what?
I never back down.
Click slop.
wait what's after the 300 six it's i don't know what's after
a billion kajillion wait does it go to a hundred does it go
to one it says it's what's wait what's more than a billion
oh trillion i have i forgot is it a kajillion the kajillion
kajillion even realize i'm so close we're almost at 300 i'm
getting another caliph just in case brazilian brazilian yeah
300 brazilian is it mintillion a real number mintillion i
think i'm i don't know reptilian i only apparently i only
count up to a billion I forgot about trillion.
I only know gazillion.
Oh yeah, is that after trillion?
It's after reptilian.
Reptillion, and then there's Calilion.
Calilion?
That's the highest anybody has ever counted before.
I was so scared of the 300, it's so easy.
But how many hours did you get to get there?
Five.
I'm on seven.
All right.
Well, are you almost 300?
No.
I only need one earth.
I'm dedicated.
I'm loyal.
I'm loyal to my earth.
All right.
Let's see what it gets you.
Holy.
I don't even know that.
Oh, my God.
Holy cow.
What?
Oh, my God.
It gives you.
I don't I don't know that number.
I'm already at it's a cow son and I already have my second
Yeah, and I have my second.
I have my third you made a son?
Yeah Yeah, and I'm about to get I'm about to get a fourth.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is a game changer Wait, this breaks the game for
real Wait the 300,000 Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god I think uh, oh my god i'm gonna get that six billion i
wonder the devs are watching they're like i wonder they're
enjoying the game i know wait i'm about to get the one after
cow sun you just got the sun cow galaxy she's not even she's
not even happy with just the sun wait i actually didn't buy
it oh now i can buy it you have the galaxy now yeah holy oh
my god what comes after galaxy okay i'm ready i'm going for
Wait, I'm sure they you know, I can't wait for them to port
this game onto steam You think like our safe files would
this okay the cow son seriously breaks the game Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I'm at supreme clicker.
I'm at cow multiverse
I think that the game is broken as hell.
I only have one, two, three, four tears left.
Nerf cow son, for real.
Nerf cow son, that's broken.
It actually is.
Wait, I'm about at eternal clicker.
Eternal clicker.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
I...
I see now.
I see...
I got the cow's done.
Yeah, once you get the cow's done, it goes insane.
Yeah, like, it's...
It changes everything.
How many cows did you get?
Uh, I don't know at the moment.
It just... It doesn't matter anymore.
It doesn't...
I have no idea.
Wait, I hope, no, devs released a new patch note.
Oh my god, I just literally...
I'm at the cow black hole.
The cow.
Okay.
Time is a con...
I don't know anything.
Time doesn't exist anymore.
It's just...
Wait, what's after the black hole?
The cow multiverse.
Okay, you're almost there.
Keep going, young one.
You can do it.
Okay, guys.
Eternal clicker.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Just keep going.
Alright, I'm clicking.
I'm clicking.
I think the next one is the black hole for me.
Yeah, the next one's going to be the black hole.
Yeah, you got the black hole.
See, it's so fast afterwards.
What is this power scaling?
The power gap.
It felt like it took me forever to get cow earth It took us
like 20 minutes to get cow earth And then like the moment we
hit cow sun The possibilities are endless There's only two
more tiers There's only two more tiers We can beat this game
We can beat this game We can beat this game We can beat it
We can beat it guys Just to be a cow clicker We were we were
We thought it would take forever from earth But no We're
we're here the cow sun power spike um i like to complain to
your devs about uh how broken cow sun is no no stop cow sun
i'm i'm team cow sun i'm team cow sun yeah yeah yeah he's
balanced the game it ruins integrity i say as i use an auto
clicker okay i'm about to get the next thing i'm about to
get the next thing hole it's singularity clicker holy
singularity clicker
uh it's not as fast as i feel like it would be not as after
the cow sun hides they're not the same yeah now i have to
get to 100 it's like so much more i feel like it needs to be
more
How many zeros is this versus this?
I think we've been clicking for like 40 minutes.
I think so too.
Sorry everybody.
But I'm not sorry because I have 19 eternal clickers.
I'm just gonna say I do not think she's sorry.
If she was sorry, this would have ended 40 minutes ago.
You could have ended it too and you didn't.
No, I can't.
No, we're so close, you guys.
We're so close.
If I ended it, you win.
Eternal Cowdom is coming.
Seek salvation in cow.
In cows we trust.
Two hour game, by the way.
Was that a lie?
You did not take into account about the cow clicker.
You were not balancing it for like document time.
Yeah.
He didn't expect VTubers to play.
The dev.
I was like, how does this scale when Doki and Mint play this
game?
We are playing the game.
You think they wrote this in their story?
The cow clicker game?
I think they wrote that they played for at least one hour of
this cow clicker game.
Or it wouldn't be in the game because it's not accurate.
Yeah, everybody.
Did you get to Singularity Clicker yet?
so many popes oh because of the auto clicker yeah growing up
and i bought like popes my bad do i actually i think i need
like at least five singularity clickers guys
yeah it doesn't go fast enough it doesn't it doesn't right a
hundred Padrillion.
Padrillion.
A Brazilian.
Okay, singularity.
I only have three singularities.
I just got my third one.
Dang it.
It's not fast enough.
It can always go faster.
It can.
It doesn't go...
Like to get singularity, take goldmine clicks too.
Mm-hmm, gold clicks.
Oh my god, I almost bought another Okay, I bought the
Singularity Okay I have to go from the left I need to stop
going from the right You're gonna go from the right accident
You go Buy a bunch of Hi I'm such a I was like, wait a
second, guys I'm not clicking I was I was about to be like,
wait, I'm not clicking No wonder it's so slow I'm not
clicking, no wonder it's so slow
Wait, so you weren't even using your clicks, your auto
clicker off, or re-clicking it manually.
Uh-oh.
What's wrong with you?
I think I'm breaking the game, Doki.
I can't hear you.
What's going on?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I have all night.
I'm wired.
This coffee's got me crazy.
Me too.
I just, yeah, I just drank.
I finished my coffee frappuccino.
Oh, that's what you ordered?
Yeah.
Got coffee and frapp.
Just what kind of frapp?
You know, the one where there's coffee in it?
This where it's blended ice and coffee.
I wonder if I should go for the hundred now.
Or do I have any more singularity clickers?
fingers hurt oh no my fingers are like so jacked up right
now there's a six pack on my finger that i'm clicking very
naturally i have an eight pack that's why it's so fast oh
yeah i'm getting my 10th pack right now it's long enough i'm
getting my 20 pack yeah that's how fast i click that's my
cow pm right now what's your cow pm um it's like the number
doesn't even exist in the strong how big it is a number
doesn't matter to me all that matters to me is cal that's
true oh wait i'm already at 20.
okay maybe this is doable but 20 what 20 what 20 out of 100
clicker oh yeah
i'm going for it i'm going for the void hundred wait how
many singularity clickers do you have only five only five
you know why don't you invest in more because they cost a
lot yeah but then by the more you invest the faster it goes
you're trying to trick me i know you did never give me
advice do not know you would never give me advice you you
you you are only trying to sabotage let's see who's laughing
when they're at the the top anymore we've we've gone beyond
time and space we are we are eternal black hole all that
matters is getting to the final tier no matter what return
of cow roi what what are you at what are you at i'm at 10
singularities now oh my god i guess i could go more but
that's fine yeah well what's your number at um oh wouldn't
you want to know
you think our parents are worried about us our dad is like
desperately texting us feel like please please answer me
yeah i think she's not saying the number guys because she
can't read it because it goes beyond human comprehension
that's how fast just say the first two just say the first
two uh the first two you won't even like you won't be able
to perceive the numbers saying i don't know yeah when you
see it it's like no it's it's like the indiana jones like
they open the chest and they die type deal if i say the
number like what what does that happen oh you're talking
about the what do you mean you've been the first movie where
they opened the fucking chest you're talking about the
ending spoilers oh my No, I'm sorry for spoiling a 30 plus
year old movie.
Let's talk about Ark of the Covenant, you guys.
Don't listen to her.
Oh, no, you definitely spoiled the movie.
At least I didn't say the title.
Because you don't know it.
Because you don't know.
No, because I was just like, you know, that in the IJones
movie.
So people who know the ending will understand the reference.
But people who don't will get spoiled.
They'll be like, oh, I wonder which movie she's talking
about.
Well, then they wouldn't watch any of them because they knew
that there was a spoiler.
No, because it's like a little gotcha, being like, oh, I
can't wait to find out which movie she's talking about.
Someone in chat was just like, mint your clicker is lagging.
Even my clicker is lagging because of my computer.
Grab one more singularity for the right road.
Alright, now I'm just gonna let it ride.
How much catch up to you?
What are you at?
Let me know.
I'm currently at 10.
Don't worry, but I'm going really fast, though.
You're at 10?
Where are you at now?
Don't worry about it.
Where are you at, huh?
You wouldn't even be able to understand.
Where are you at?
Oh, I know it's not a hundred.
I know.
How do you know?
I know it's not.
Because you would have bought the hundred.
Be like, oh, guess who just got it?
Let it count.
What are you at?
Tell me right now where is Mintz at, spies?
Tell me, you guys tell me right now.
You're at 40?
I'm at 40 because I'm not embarrassed.
Guess who's almost at 50.
94.
96.
County up right now.
97.
I'm 60, 61, 99, 63, 64, 65.
Oh, she's out of here.
Cow Singularity Core acquired.
Cow Singularity Core.
I will say, I will say the ending might, the ending might be
not as creative as the others.
I would.
Doki, I...
From Singularity to Singularity Core.
Yeah, right.
Also, Doki, I didn't even get an achievement for that.
You didn't get an achievement?
I think I'm done with Cow Game.
I think I'm pissed off right now.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I need to get it first, too.
The Singularity Core is kind of mad.
I don't know.
Yeah, actually, it's kind of mad.
I'm not going to lie.
Actually, it's kind of mad.
core it doesn't even give me that many clicks though it
doesn't it's only per second yeah yeah it's only per second
it's not even what's that word when the ending of a movie is
pretty mediocre like it's like anti-climactic or yeah yeah
that felt so anti-climatic you know you know i'm done me too
i'm done i'm gonna get one more i almost did record and
playback uh let me turn yeah i'm done i'm done yeah i think
i i'm done i think i'm cowed out
wake up wake up we've been standing here for wait why did
you just text me but you're right here oh house cow clicker
mid okay i have an idea what would it be really fun if we
reset our cows and started all over again
we got to get the high again yeah what were we doing i think
we're moving or something um oh yeah we are oh trailer for
the day and it's almost nighttime oh my god stop slamming
your head like oh hide in the trailer we're gonna have to
hide here wait do you see our mic yeah i see our mic meter
i'm getting out of here i'm running away i'm running away
Help me, help me, help me, help me, help me.
I'm being trapped.
I'm being held hostage.
Please, somebody!
Being held hostage by a crazy person.
Oh, that girl's creepy.
Are you kissing her?
You're my boyfriend, aren't you?
What the hell are you doing with her?
What are you doing with her?
I think that she made a move on me!
Oh, she's trying to think of the trash!
See?
No, you were in her face.
You were like, hey, baby girl, what are you doing tonight?
She made a move on me.
faithful i don't believe that at all everybody how will you
spend who spent one hour cooking cows with you huh who was
it that's true that's true that's right don't worry i'll
wander our carpet it took fine we're moving anyway so we're
just deep cleaning we're deep cleaning it was called
cleaning simulator yeah yeah yeah wait do we actually need
to what do we need to do we have like no no we have a goal
it's just cows oh wait I was trying to change my...
Oh my god, there's no sensitivity.
You can't change your sense in this game.
No, you can't.
Oh!
You have to grab...
I think we actually have to pack.
Oh shit, okay.
Wait, it's just real life.
It's just... This is literally what I've been doing.
Oh my god.
I'm throwing this shit.
I yet the best just packing simulator.
We're prepping you for it tonight.
Oops.
Where are the others?
I can talk to you.
One more.
Wait, there's the basement.
The basement's scary.
Wait, get the flashlight.
Yeah, I got it.
All right, let's go.
You first!
You took the flashlight!
My lady.
Give me the flashlight.
I'll go.
I'm here to... I will shine it in front of you.
Oh, wait.
There's light down here.
Exactly.
Grab that.
I said one left.
grab that you said one left I'm in maxing I need two it's
two to grab come here come here Marcus okay come on come on
okay I need you here I need you here what's up what's up
this one okay come on come on come on come on yeah you good
over Yeah.
No, I'm asking you... Oh, you're fine?
All right.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, it's dropping, I think.
Wait, come on.
I'm moving it.
Oh, oh, oh, it's gonna drop.
I think.
Uh-oh.
You good?
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait, grab it.
Here.
Oh, oh, wait.
Can we jump over it?
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got this.
No.
You're trying to hear.
I got this.
I got... Wait, don't push it.
Don't push it!
I had it!
I got it, I got it!
Okay, okay.
You're good?
We're good?
I'm such a good boyfriend.
I'm so good at this moving shit.
Yeah, come over.
Help me out.
Yeah, but then you won't learn how to do it yourself.
You gotta be independent.
Oh my god, come on.
Alright.
Why are you, like, tilting it all over the place?
What are you doing?
Oh, okay.
All right.
You think I'm tilting you?
Okay.
Come on.
Come
on.
Who the hell are you?
Who the fuck is this guy?
Hey, he made me drop my thing.
You're like, you're like hanging on.
You're supposed to leave this morning.
We might have put, we might have downloaded cow clicker.
Yeah.
Come on.
A little blind.
Did you just do a flip?
inside the wait is there a way to jump in this game yeah
there is how oh okay now i'm doing it for some reason i
wouldn't i don't know i don't know bro but at this point
it's happening either way just want to get moving at this
point Hold it.
Whoa.
You know this was the 90s.
No, last night was fun, man.
Fun, man.
Yeah.
Next time we're back.
Yeah, bro.
Well, you two need a hand with anything.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I was just running.
Make sure write a story about us and then have us act voice
act.
Peace out, homie.
Oh my God.
Yeah, peace out.
I'll miss you two.
You couldn't even.
Yeah.
Get me out of here.
she's trapping me please please oh my god are you hitting at
him no wow on the last day smile you're on camera what do we
need to do now what the fuck did you do i auto-clickered on
the
wait do i just wait let me Let me try.
Let me try.
Alright, alright.
Oh, you're on a cliff.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
We could go.
Oh, shit.
Where would we go?
My door's open.
Where are we going?
I don't know.
I'm turning on some jams, though.
Dang.
I wasn't the best at driving.
I should have let Marcus drive as well.
Yeah.
You get back behind them.
I wonder why.
Look, it's not as easy as it looks, okay?
Oh, wait.
I'm stuck on something.
Wait, we left our suitcase in the garage.
Wait, we have a suitcase.
We left something in the garage.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Where's our house?
Uh.
Yeah.
By the way.
oh yeah i told them they were saying like uh they were
asking me uh about driving saying like i'm i'm a bad driver
yeah and then i was like okay what was it i actually forgot
the punchline
anyway i'm i'm a streamer you guys uh-huh we're gonna get
our stuff from the garage how do i get out oh space to get
up yeah yeah space you can drive next time all right i'm
going grab stuff wait are there more boxes to pack no they
said we forgot our suitcase in the garage oh wait but
there's more boxes he said i don't fucking know there's like
boxes at the bottom too wait i gotta take our fridge i'm Oh
my god, I'm so strong.
7-8.
Oh, unlock.
What other boxes are we missing?
Oh, jeez.
Are you being a fridge?
Or Samsung fridge?
Oh, now you open the door.
Oh.
You forgot to pick you when I put the fridge in.
Oh, yeah, make sure you keep cleaning.
I am, I am.
It's a power wash simulator.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
There's a... I got one here.
I got one.
Power Wash Simulating 3.
Yippee!
Yipp!
This is exactly what my trailer looks like, too.
Wee-wee-wee-me-mee.
Did she even look for boxes?
Did she even look like actually did you even look wait,
where did you find this box?
Wait, there's literally one in the kitchen, too Stop stop
I can't read
Oh wait, there is one more box my god.
Why did you buy all this shit?
Actually, we're like leaving everything behind is this so oh
wait, there's another wait, that's not one Is this one?
No.
Just towels in the tub.
Wait about this.
Oh, our microwave.
We need our microwave.
Oh, that's so true.
Nice.
I like how it actually has weight.
Yeah, we need that.
We need our TV.
Oh, my God, our toaster.
We cannot forget.
Wait, did you get the air fryer?
Did you get the air fryer?
Wait, was air fryer's invented back then?
How do you know we're in the 90s?
wait nice all right do we get everything that should be
everything right I don't know what about our table where are
we going to eat at where are we going to eat at if we don't
have a table
that the box does not hold a table
oh yeah we do have smartphones I'm not the one saying we're
in the 90s it's Doki the floor what about what about this
cone I think we're good wait what about the suitcases in the
garage you said
how did you drive I just went oh wait there's a GPS oh okay
bye okay bye oh shoot I'm in oh shh i'm fine all right all
right drive by you got this we have a killer with us you
gotta practice this okay i'm i'm in i'm in i'm in i'm in i'm
in i'm in okay okay okay okay open my gps me too i can for
legal reasons i did not indulge in texting and driving okay
i all right where are we going where are we going i don't
know i can't text and drive it's not there's nothing on GPS
it's not immersive it's not immerse don't you miss it in the
90s when you get texted everybody was texting and driving in
the 90s everybody was doing it in the 90s oh I think we got
to get the trailer oh shit get up get up get up get me out
wait hold on okay two two hour long game everybody oh
there's a car honking at you right now Oh The car Wait, you
have to come over here You have to come over here Six point
turn This person
Alright, now we got an exchange license
Okay, alright sir Please get out so we can exchange license
There it was his fault Right?
Oh my god, Tessa.
It was his fault.
Okay, I'm gonna save- I'm gonna save this.
Wait, oh wait, I'm in the- how- what seat am I in?
Did I get in the back seat?
Wait, I can't get out.
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Never punished.
Yeah, fuck you!
Fuck you!
Oh shoot, I'm stuck again.
Alright, we did it guys.
people are so impatient.
Oh, get out of my way!
Beep, beep.
Okay, but the game is saying I should have let you drive, so
it's like a mini-game.
You have to go.
Okay, I gotta go now.
Okay, how do we go?
Okay, wait, no, no, no, no, please.
Not like this!
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
This is the run.
I was in the car with her while she was driving, guys.
I did drive you once.
Oops.
And I live to tell the tale.
Okay.
I think...
We can connect it here.
We can connect it.
That's what I'm saying.
Are we close?
Are we close enough?
No.
What do you think?
Okay.
I'm backing up.
Car was parked a little too far at first to hunt.
Did I make it?
Yeah, you made it.
You made it.
All right.
Maybe I should sit in the back seat.
Okay.
It's safer, right?
My passenger princess, where would you like us to go?
reasons i did not indulge in texting and driving oh yeah
that's what i got too okay where am i going i don't know i
have it says no route selected uh we miss loading some of
our stuff at first wait what do you mean what do you what
did we miss what did we miss what did we miss we got
everything i think we we missed some stuff i'm checking i
like how we left all the doors Oh, oh!
My luggage!
Our...
Wait, oh, you found...
Wait, there's also a whole couch.
Our luggage, it was right here.
Oh, it should have not blended in.
Yeah.
The luggage.
Wait, come help me with this couch.
Marcus.
Oh, we are bringing our couch.
Wait, this is not gonna fit.
Don't lift it like that.
You'll hurt your back.
Yeah, it will.
Don't lift it like that as you were like hunched over.
Okay, okay, grab it.
I told you.
You're like fully hunched over.
Oh my god, what do you do?
A man needs a chunk.
Grab it!
What are you doing?
I'm trying!
Why are you letting go?
Because you were letting go.
Come on!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I did my job.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I saw that.
I saw that.
Come on.
Because you're not working fast enough.
That's how I looked earlier.
I have to open this.
Yeah.
Marcus is heavy.
Okay, where's the luggage?
Apparently it should have been, like, on the...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I could have threw it.
I think I did left it.
Where's our luggage?
Apparently it should have been in the trunk, so I'm trying
to find it.
Oh, what did you do?
with it no i don't where did it go did i chuck it and
transport it into the wait there's this is here is that our
luggage no no it was it was like oh i threw it all the way
in there okay i'm gonna go check for anything else i'm
checking for anything this is suddenly a moving sim real
terror oh i don't want to think about moving anymore this is
supposed to be my break and i'm having to moving what about
our grill we don't want that oh i put the suitcase in the
trunk oh nice she did it she figured it out she figured it
out i like the creepy music while everything is happening
um i found a box oh my god how did she miss this i found a
box where did you find that box Yeah, that's what I'm
saying.
Alright, alright, now we get the couch.
I got this in.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Alright, go on in.
Yep.
Yep, you're good.
How do I get out?
You're good.
I'll make you no clip through.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, drop.
Alright, um...
Um, I don't think I can clip through this.
Wait, wait, wait, unless...
Oh, I did it!
wait it's not going in no how are you gonna get the couch
okay we got tetris this wait wait wait wait maybe we can fit
we oh are you okay i don't know what just happened to be
tripped and fell you know that life alert okay hold on our
toaster is really important but it can go in the bag okay
it's lid all right hold on we're so good at packing all
right shove it in shove it in shove it in oh you need we're
still in the tutorial right now which is happening to me oh
you're moonwalking this is sick huh look into the trailer
when you right click it's all green well oh that's probably
stuff we need to grab it's like a hint oh my god I'm green
I'm right-clicking everything.
I'm using my vision I'm doing the meta the meta strap the
meta I think that's everything wait, what is this?
Carl Costa Rica Wait is the couch not highlighted?
I think I would not survive What I said I'm glad I hoarded
coffee.
I do not think I would I'm What are you talking about?
Alright, come on, come on.
Wait, is it not?
Oh, I guess...
We're not bringing the couch, man!
We're gonna buy a new couch, Tessa.
Okay.
Oh, it has bed bugs or something, probably.
Okay, you drive, you drive.
Oh, I'll drive, okay.
Yeah.
That's right.
Clearly the superior driver should take the front seat.
Yeah, I kept telling me that Marcus should drive every time
I got into an accident.
Wait, we missed loading something?
What did we miss?
It's the couch!
What do you mean?
What did we miss?
Let me get up.
Space?
Space to get up?
Uh-oh.
Guys.
We gotta read Tetris this.
I can't get up.
Wait, wait.
I have an idea.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
What are you doing?
Stop!
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to drive.
I'm just reaching over and I'm walking.
Oh my god.
I can get out.
Oh, I can get out.
What did you even do?
I just... I don't know.
I drove the car a little bit to the left.
Okay, we got to run.
Okay, I think we have to put all these stuff out and then
put the couch in.
No, no, no.
I'm just moving it to the back.
I'm moving it to the back.
All right.
Here, let's move this a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
I'm gone now.
I don't think we made it worse.
I think we made it worse.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, let's do it, let's do it, let's do it, we got this.
We got this, we got this, we got this, this is moving to you
later at this point.
We got that box!
Okay, then take it out.
Who's honking the horn?
Someone's taking our car!
And it was blocking the road!
Maybe we do have to take everything out.
Oh yeah, now we- wait, wait, wait, wait!
This is it!
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta get rid of the...
Fine!
Oh my god, I mean, fine, fine.
This is what they wanted!
Oh, how did that happen?
Oh, you guys, women, am I right?
Help me with this one.
No, no, that's fine.
We've just pushed them.
We have so much space.
Oh, okay, you're right.
Okay, come here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, come on, come on, come on.
This is the horror aspect trying to move.
And then it has to pack after this tree.
I know!
Wait, I'm stuck.
Yeah, we did it!
We did it!
We fucking did it!
Oh.
I love being able to clip through the car.
Alright.
Okay, easy.
Alright, easy.
okay i'm trying to oh my god
oh my god oh my god what's going on with you what's going on
going on why am i so tall you've been all don't tell me it's
nothing can we just go oh you're the What happened
yesterday?
Wait, why do I have a knife all of a sudden?
I said I'm fine, Marcus.
Yeah, are you fine?
What I said at Jake's came out wrong.
Yeah.
That's not how I meant it.
We have 15 minutes till it hits two hours.
We drive out of the house and the game ends.
Probably.
You don't have to come.
Yeah, that was the horror.
It's my thing.
You're not ready.
Stop.
I'm serious.
Why did I get a knife?
It's not too late to.
I said stop.
Then what is it?
What is it?
Yeah.
Can I just not be right now?
Why is she being so emotional?
I don't know.
Something happened last night.
She downloaded cow clicker last night.
That's what happened.
She's like, you used an auto clicker and I was trying to
play Fairleaf.
Can you just not talk to me?
You're like, um, CalClicker was my thing and she just had to
ruin my thing.
You just, you got better at it than me and I'm just really
emotional right now.
Let's just go.
You had your gardening and I had CalClicker and you just had
to ruin it for me.
This guy's been, oh my gosh, look at the car pile up.
There's
so...
I hope, I hope that I did, I didn't check if the audio was
good.
So I hope the audio has been good the entire time.
I'm sure it's fine.
Alright, how are we gonna get out of here though?
Alright!
Well now we can leave.
Oh now they go?
Oh now they leave.
What's wrong with them?
Why can't I start the car?
Wait, just start the car.
We made good time on the loading.
Shut the door.
I can't.
Why can't I turn on my car?
That's the radio?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, let me check the navigator.
Yeah, check the navigator.
It doesn't show anything.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Where do we go?
I don't know.
I'm just driving.
Oh, oh, oh.
Fade the black.
What's happening?
Don't care.
She can't hear me.
Oh, she's talking.
7.40 p.m.
Credits roll.
Oh, hello?
Hi.
Hey.
I think...
Oh, stay on 205 West for two miles.
This should be about four hours for the game.
Four hours?
I thought this was a two-hour game.
It's like real-time driving.
I'm kind of hungry.
Me and eat bathroom breaks.
Tessa says she's okay.
Warning, prepare to meet goo.
What?
That sign just said, prepare to meet goo.
This is DJ.
Can we turn off the music, please?
This is...
We got a situation.
Um...
Eyes on the road, Doki Bird.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, I have a text for my dad.
Oh, you're gonna check this?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
He didn't text me.
Yeah, he texted me.
Keep me updated, Marcus.
Oh.
Does he not know you're driving?
This is such...
Yeah.
This is so bad.
Oh, I got a message from Marcus.
Check text.
Oh, shit.
He didn't message me.
Yeah, your dad doesn't love you.
Oh, that's exactly what I was typing.
Yeah.
Yeah, pass that guy.
Pass that guy.
I'm going to give him a finger as you do it.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Doggy.
It's like bumper cars.
Who's honking at us?
I know.
A decent kitchen, apparently.
Oh, take Exit 5.
Take Exit 5.
Okay, Exit 5.
Who texted you that?
The Navigator, my only friend.
Nobody else texts me except the Navigator.
Your wife is back?
Your wife is hot.
That thing...
Oh, my God!
Wait, don't forget to take Exit 5.
Where's Exit 5?
Okay, you're supposed to look it for me.
It's now.
It's right now.
Yeah, it's right now.
Oh, right here.
I think I turned my back.
blinker on you think it hit stay on this for 40 miles 40
miles yeah keep going something good enough for both of us
looking at PCs are you trying to be a gamer yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna be the next big streamer on what's the one pre
twitch I don't remember traffic bad could be worse terrible
help me all right why why am I swerving to the left I don't
know our alignment's bad.
I don't know Justin TV.
What's that?
Yeah, Justin TV.
Yeah, that's yeah, I won't be the next big streamer at
Justin TV.
What is Justin TV?
It was basically that is Twitch before Twitch.
God, you're old.
How did you know that?
Justin TV.
Ah, because I'm a gamer.
I know my history.
Never forget your history where you came from.
I never came from Twitch.
Oh, important traffic alert.
Oh, it's congested.
Okay.
I'll reroute.
I'm looking for a new route.
Okay.
I'm glad you're doing your job.
Uh, take the exit to Cascade Highway.
Cascade Highway.
In, um, 0.8 miles.
Alright.
We're 60 miles away from it.
Oh, this feels like final destination.
Oh.
Oh, new message.
I would stop this car right now.
I would...
You have to get all the way
out.
Oh, I can't get up.
No.
That's fucking right.
It says you're typing, are you?
No.
Oh, it's creepy.
Whoa, that's where I was like, ghost is.
That's the ghost.
Oh.
Oh
He's just my coach.
Oh, yeah, your late-night cooking coaching session.
Yeah, that's what they all say Yeah, the late-night coach
session Where were you last day?
Not the late-night coke session
R Wait, I think that's our exit.
Yeah, yeah.
Is that our exit?
Yeah, that's our exit.
It was literally right next door.
Oh, that's...
I don't know why I'm sweating!
What the hell?
It's right there.
Are you blind?
Why did you turn?
Okay, I'll drive.
I'll drive.
Wait, it won't let me out of the car again.
It won't let me out!
Oh my god.
I swear to you guys, you text me right now.
I swear to you guys.
Whoa!
I want to get home!
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Oh hey, there's cow crossing.
Do you see that?
No.
Where?
Oh, nice!
You made it!
Still loading for the other survivor.
What the hell does that mean?
808 p.m.
It only took us one hour to get there.
We're here.
No, we're not.
We're still on the road.
We're still driving.
Oh, stay on the highway for 2.7 miles.
Okay, that's fine.
That should be fine.
Are you sober?
Are you safe to drive?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, no, that's not cow crossing.
Oh, there's avalanche.
Oh, who's texting you?
Who's texting you?
I can't get up It's getting really windy out there By the
way, okay, I'll read it for you.
What'd you say?
Um Sorry pops interstate had a blockage so we're talking to
a detour Through Roseburg that you know once we get back to
the main road interstate and there's not a single car on
this road yeah where are the car i know wait yeah one passed
by no yeah let me let me get out let me get out or let me
see how in our text okay gave me a thumbs up wait this is
not the 90s why do we have like this phone is not why did
you
I was like I love texting on my phone in the 90s.
Why are you running into the why are you so blind just drive
straight?
Touchpad Give me up give me up You're stuck in here with me
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Yeah, I was gonna say where's my blueberry like where's my
blueberry?
Your blueberry Blueberry
because it's copyrighted.
Oh, sorry.
We don't want to get sued.
You're so right.
Um, okay, just keep going straight.
Keep going straight.
Yeah, it's like the Samsung, the Samsung fridge.
Oh.
Remember our Samsung fridge in the trailer?
Oh, my God!
Oh, shit.
Marcus?
You okay?
Are you okay?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, now you can get up.
All right.
deep breath what do we do what do we do what do we do what
do we do what do we do what do we do do we move it moving
the tree it all right let's go i have a 10 pack from cow
clicker yeah me too me too we can shift it enough to get
through okay all right i'm grabbing it grab the other side
yeah well you're actually grabbing the yeah i'm grabbing it
i'm lifting the whole tree holy cow
Doki be a team player which way are you going I'm going
towards you wherever we want okay I think that's good right
I think that's fine right yeah we can go through we could go
through we go to the left women in stem women in stem Wait,
there's...
Wait, there's somebody running.
Yeah, did you see that?
Yeah, I saw that.
Wait, let's talk to him.
He opened our... He opened our thing!
He's so... Wait!
I have a flashlight in here, no?
Wait, where'd my flashlight go?
Did he steal our stuff?
Wait, is the couch still in here?
Okay, thank goodness.
You were just looking at a PC.
Everything goes to Steam nowadays.
Valve hasn't made Steam yet.
I think we should go after him.
Where did he go?
This way.
This is probably his car.
We rob him back.
Oh, that's true.
I'm taking his...
Well, he was a gardener.
Yeah.
He's a handyman.
Oh, I walked through his car.
Let's just get back to the car.
Yeah, let's just go.
yeah getting late what if another tree falls there all right
you drive okay don't
make me pull this car you have to navigate me now uh for one
mile okay just go straight yeah just go straight okay whoa
that's a train yeah uh 0.7 miles okay look at that you're
like oh see there is another car yeah this is totally fine i
don't even know yeah what were you worried about i would be
worried about trees falling oh who's texting you oh point
two miles to the right oh just no one who's texting you no
you it's all right it's just someone i know from work you
know oops oh oh yeah and You were talking about my driving.
Couldn't even do a right turn.
Did you turn your blinker on?
I'm going to crash this car.
I'm going to crash it.
I'm going to crash.
I'm flooring it right now.
I'm flooring it.
We're going to go off the bridge.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, what's happening?
What is that?
That was not me.
A light on the dash came on.
Wait, that wasn't me.
That was definitely your fault.
Oh, because you started driving.
Oh, now, look at that.
I could feel this car struggle on the head.
No, this is a setup.
This is a setup.
Because men started driving.
Suddenly all these problems came up, guys.
Stop yelling at me.
I didn't get any of these issues before when I was driving.
I'm making it with a good job.
Oh.
Look at that.
You're getting honked at now.
Uh-oh.
Wait, why is your door open?
Why are your doors open?
Oh shit.
What?
Is this a chase scene?
It's just go around.
Oh, oh no!
Our car's on fire!
Oh no, our car broke down!
I'm going?
Wait, actually I can't go.
Wait, you gotta fix the car.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Wait, hold on.
Uh, hold on.
Hold on.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
We're fine.
All right.
All right, we're good.
We're driving, we're driving.
Don't worry about the engine fire.
Don't worry about it.
We can go to this motel.
Oh, I'm sick.
I'm gonna drive in the middle of the road.
This guy's pissing me off.
Oh, now we have two people.
Oh, you're hot.
You're doing that.
Yeah.
Oh, he went around.
Oh, you finally went around.
What else to deal with that guy?
Real.
Like, relax, bitch.
Damn.
Yeah, bitch.
Okay, um, the light.
Not even the light, the smoke?
Yeah, the smoke on the engine?
These trees are hanging real low.
Yeah.
God, that must have been the guy in our car, right?
8.52 p.m.
Oh, we almost hit that tree.
It didn't go away.
I drove a little bit more before we accepted the car wasn't
going to fix itself.
He found the only shop in the area in his GPS.
The other survivor is still reading.
The other survivor was still reading.
Oh, what a shock.
It was a bad driver you were.
It was like three pages long.
Oh, no, no.
Just give me a step by step of how bad your driving was.
No, mine was that.
Mine said how many times you ran into things.
And your number...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's why it was so fast for you to read, because it was,
like, one sentence.
No, no.
It was three times that.
The damn car overheated.
Not sure what we're going to do.
We found a service station.
I'm going to say about getting the car fixed.
Wait, is that the service station?
No route selected.
Was that the service station?
It's a gas station, so I think so.
I don't know.
It's gotta be.
Alright, alright, you can get us.
Ah, car troubles.
Classic horror.
Do we...
Nothing could prepare us for what came next.
Is it here?
I think so.
I guess.
Yeah, yeah.
Help us!
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
Yeah, let's go.
Yeah, oh hey, there's my Marlo.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Ginger.
Hello anybody here?
Oh, hair dye.
I thought it was a calendar dedicated to Ginger's.
Match the carpet with the drapes!
Oh my god.
Say hello to Ginger.
Oh, there's so.
Oh, hello.
Why is the door open?
Hello.
No one here.
I think we're supposed to go over there.
I think we go to the light, right?
Yeah.
Boo.
The sign says open.
This place smells weird.
It smells weird here.
It smells like gas because we're next to it.
Ah!
Wait, my heart's beating.
Is your heart beating?
Yeah, howdy-do.
I'm expecting a tanker in the morning, though.
our car needs fixing yeah yeah you actually we were driving
up and had a light come on in the dash about 20 minutes back
it's uh the red one we were hoping someone here could take a
look temperature light maybe i don't know anything about
cars no it's you're gonna upcharge us it was uh uh we're
headed north actually we're just headed up north He got a
new job That's right.
I got promoted.
Yeah Yeah Because everybody here knows about cars.
Just don't see a lot of Of what, huh?
What?
Of what, huh?
What's wrong with us?
Scratch creeps a long way from anywhere you.
They don't see a lot of women.
And then I guess black people?
It's just Oh, follow me.
Let's follow him.
Oh, okay.
Okay, we're following him.
Oh, he's following us.
We're following him.
Oh, we got to the car.
Oh, he's walking?
He's like staring at me, though.
I think he really has never seen a woman before in his life.
I really like that he's staring at you.
He's staring at me!
I'm running away!
Oh, who's Ellie?
Oh, rah!
Hell, this has been a disaster.
Last night was a maze balls, you guys.
My name's Harold.
Harold Sweeney?
Sweeney?
The demon barber of Fleet Street!
He's gonna say Sweeney died!
This is my girlfriend, Tessa.
Is this the cow coach?
You were texting last night?
He's always cowin'.
What does that mean?
I'm gonna step outside their circle.
by the way just so you know i didn't mean to scare you back
there i was just doing some scraping work um yeah she dated
out of her cow circle my cow i had i had a supernova she had
a son it was just his so yeah she was a competitive
counselor she wouldn't think she would settle for someone
Take him to the car!
Oh, sorry, my friend is texting me!
Why?
Who are you texting?
It's Ellie, you wouldn't understand.
Oh my god, wait, they have coffee break.
Where is he?
Oh, good.
Help us, help us!
Oh my god, it's on fire!
Please!
It's on fire!
Bang it!
Bang that wrench.
I mean, I could have done the same thing, you know?
Yeah, why don't you make yourself useful?
I'm lagging.
So, tell me, how two people different as you get together.
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
I'm not sure I follow.
What are you trying to say?
I mean, I was just curious.
CalClicker was my first mobile game.
It was not the kind of thing you brought them to.
He's like, I start, I'm more used to girls starting with
Flapy Cow.
I think I found the problem.
But, just a second.
Yeah, we don't need small talk.
Just fix the car, buddy.
Yeah, just fix our car.
Just fix our car.
Am I the problem?
That's what I figured.
What?
What is it?
I think I can help you out.
What?
What's the wrong with the car?
That's my man.
Oh, what is it?
Cool and lick.
That's my man.
Racist.
I was so chill about that, damn.
Either of you notice anything before it died on you.
It started struggling up the hill.
Yeah.
It started struggling on the hill.
the hill the temperature needle shot up out of nowhere yep
that lines up who's this guy he'll stay right here i will
stay right here he doesn't want to fix her car he's trying
to charge us like 20 times because he knows i know nothing
about cars he's trying to sell our he's trying to get our
cows yeah yeah he's trying to get oh wait did you get text
yeah Daddy, our car broke down.
Oh, wait.
I just got to think.
Mari called me.
You two left the garage door open.
Dad, that's not the issue right now.
That's not the issue here.
Are you talking about us?
Probably.
Yeah, let's go over there and check it out.
Oh, he's coming back.
He's coming back.
Hey.
Oh, got another text.
i wish you'd called sweetie you two need to give me me you
need you you wait i'm sorry i accidentally took a screech
what what did he say you said you said wait wait you go back
you said you could take care of it yeah oh my god you have
an echo now then i thought it looks like the head gasket is
about to go out whole things uh you said you had the parts
though we we don't This guy, it's this guy.
Oh my god, wait, it's Walter White.
Oh, it's Walter White!
It's Walter White!
What are we gonna do?
Walter White?
Is it the bathroom?
It's because this is not a real gas station.
That's true.
He used to be a mechanic here.
But retired a few years back.
Okay, Harry.
The fella still does some work at his house.
Oh, he want us to go to his house?
Harry, we gotta cook.
His house.
Car won't make it though.
something yeah make it any further actually this happened to
me not too long ago on the highway told you we can't help
there he'll do a little patch job on the engine that'll get
you as far as bills out it'll get you as far as you try to
get back on the highway you look at this guy definitely
smokes this guy is yeah this guy smokes like a first second
he has a SPM.
Smoke for a minute.
Harry.
Now.
He commands him.
Welcome to books.
24 hours.
24 hours morning.
Um.
I don't want to give him money.
No.
We can go to the bathroom.
You need to go to the bathroom.
Oh, go to the bathroom then.
Okay.
Yeah, I need to use the restroom.
Just gotta hit the bathroom before we leave.
Yeah.
Yeah, slap him.
I'll buy something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll grab a snack.
I just wanted to look around.
Maybe grab a snack.
We're out of snacks.
Oh my god!
Wait, what if I ask?
Yeah, what if I ask?
Yeah, what if she goes in?
Yeah.
He can't be sexist.
Wait, he, he, he won't let me talk to him.
He is, he's also, he's sexist too!
Oh my god!
I was like, there's no way he can be both.
This guy plays cigarette clicker.
Ah!
Thanks for nothing, Harry.
Yeah, thanks for nothing, Harry.
Fucking whipped us hell.
Yeah, for real.
We're gonna show you something crazy.
A woman driver.
Yeah, yeah!
And I'm a good one.
I'm a good one.
Here we go.
We are progressive.
How do I start my car?
Wait, how do I start?
the car.
You can't say that after I told them about what we're
driving.
Yeah.
Oh, that's...
Oh, sorry.
It's okay.
She meant to do that.
Wait, where am I going?
I need you to navigate me.
I have no route selected.
I assume you just go straight.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, but there's a turn here.
I don't fucking know my GPS.
Just tell me where to go, Marcus.
Come on.
up for that we oh my god we're about to get hit by this
truck i think we go straight right okay i'll go straight i
said you are a great driver i am i am i'm making it i'm
making it all right all right then we just go straight and
then it'll give us like a blackout cutscene yeah it's so
true you're right you're right you're right yeah yeah yeah
i'm going it's really slow any minute now any oh The last
story is short, they couldn't fix the car, but said some guy
named Bill can take a look.
Where is Bill's house?
Oh, I thought I was fading the black.
Oh, is it here?
No?
Where are we?
No.
No trespassing.
We're going to go straight.
But it said not to go on the highway.
Who's Bill?
Some mechanic, they said we are almost here.
I'll text you.
Go to sleep.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, somebody rated that girl.
Oh.
Any minute, fade it back.
Uh-oh.
The car couldn't take the climb anymore.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Here, I'll just keep going forward.
Oh, I think this is an invisible wall.
Oh, okay.
So we missed the turn.
Yeah.
We missed the turn.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
The car will fix itself when we're off that road.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
It's going so slow, though.
Yeah, it's like a little...
Like, I'm not even, actually, it's just the hill going down.
I'm not even, I'm not even on the.
All right, it's fine.
It doesn't, it doesn't move anymore.
Where the fuck is Bill?
Where are we supposed to go?
I don't want my, my not go isn't working.
You know what is working?
What?
Cow clicker.
No, no, I need you right now.
Don't you stop!
Oh, wait, the car is moving again.
Okay, we're good.
All right, nice.
Is it here?
I feel like it's here.
This looks like Bill's house, right?
Is that Bill's house?
It says no trespassing, but I think it's fine for tonight.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
That's where the spooky stuff happens.
That should be.
He's probably really kind, and we'll fix the car for...
Oh, my dad's texting me.
Oh, that means we're going the right way because it's
progressing.
Oh, you're right.
Wait.
Wait, I don't think it's the right way.
Wait, why don't you think so?
No, it didn't.
I'm checking my text.
Hey, kiddo, don't leave me hanging.
We are near Roseburg.
We found a mechanic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had a similar text for my dad, too.
Your dad, right?
That's what you call her.
Dad, you call her daddy.
Wait, what was that?
That's your text.
Wait, what's that sound?
I'm doing this alone.
Why is the music all like?
Wait, that has to be where Bill is, right?
This has to be, this has to be.
Yeah, that's Bill's place.
Why is the music like this?
Do you hear it?
Oh, yeah, I hear it.
I hear it.
All right, let's get it.
Why is it like this?
Maybe Bill's here.
Hello?
Yeah, yeah, do you hear that violin?
Yeah, it's going crazy.
Yeah, yeah, it's like, weeer.
Because I think...
I'll knock oh, I tried opening the door.
I just tried opening their door Yeah, I'm gonna stand over
to the side just yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, don't let them yeah
They have a welcome mat.
They're probably fine Oh, they're probably you know, I don't
want to get this, you know, you know the movie get out
Oh, hello She Uh-oh, and his wrath she's kind of kooky oh no
instrument of his wrath myself if you don't get off my porch
you got the wrong idea I think you got the wrong idea you're
not from the new temple the new temple Marcus what did I
tell you to stay over there I'm looking for bill we're
looking yeah we're looking we were told to look for a
mechanic named bill we're having some trouble with her car
yeah i did i did i told her we're looking for bill
oh billy was boys a little social shows so the awkward how
do you know what if we go find them Billy boy!
Billy boy!
Oh, must be the ones Buck warned me about.
Yes!
Oh, okay,
good.
Okay, that's good.
Then you know, yeah, you know everything, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, he knows.
That's us.
We need help.
Buck sent us your way.
The man at the station told us it was probably a coolant
leak, then backed out and wouldn't fix it.
Could you please take a look sir Billy boy Hey Billy See
look the moment I started talking he was not very happy.
Yeah What do you what you can't see the car from here?
You have to yeah Yeah, it's over here.
Yeah, it's over here.
Made to haul a trailer engines hot as hell.
Oh, that's my bad You're lucky you've got a coolant leak if
you ain't it's a blown head gasket and your oil's turning
into soup.
Oh, no Oh no!
You didn't even take a look.
Yeah.
Fixing engines longer than y'all been alive.
I know what I'm looking at.
But you don't know.
I have a custom engine in here.
Yeah.
What if...
What do we do?
Yeah.
What are we gonna do until morning?
I ain't running a motel here.
What'd we say?
You're welcome to sleep in your car out here if you want.
Oh.
Okay.
Actually, I don't want to go in there.
That's true.
Oh, okay.
Well, I guess we're sleeping inside.
The high power wouldn't have sink you here if we weren't
meant to take care of you.
All right.
All right, okay.
You're right where you ought to be.
Let me in.
That's not creepy at all.
Miss Julia's got room.
I bet she makes a mean pie.
She'll take you.
I bet she.
I bet she makes a best pie.
Ooh, some meat.
Miss Julia.
Yeah, who's Miss Julia?
Miss Julia?
sweet old lady who runs a bed and breakfast up the hill ah i
had to go up the hill now we're needy we're needy um i got
promoted that's right the great we got upgraded to a new tax
bracket yeah uh where is her place yeah walking distance
actually i'm not sure if this car should even move anymore
your friend buck told us it'd be a catastrophic engine
failure.
You won't be needing your car to get there.
Okay, good.
Take this little trail behind the...
We're going in the... Okay.
Do you have a flashlight?
I'm running a little... Yeah, do you have a flashlight?
Uh, a little spooky.
I don't know if you're a rival.
She'll be waiting with a warm room.
I like that.
She said it like, uh... I know.
To the trail.
Yeah, look.
Okay.
Spooky.
Don't step off it.
Not even once.
You won't like what happens.
It happens to you.
It's booby trapped.
there's landmines yeah you guys aren't a cult right that's
such a boring trope come on she said maybe she said out
there's the out there's another cult though like the tempo
oh yeah the temple cult yeah maybe that's what they like
it's not like rival cults but my cult is better than your
cult uh we're the cult of cow have you ever heard of us
all right i guess we go to the trail now i think no he's
coming back with something i think yeah come here oh he was
yeah oh he's got a flashlight i packed our flashlight yeah
we did catch it battery's good don't drop it okay thanks all
right that's enough for tonight trails back there goes right
up the hill don't waste time all right let's go let's go
program we're going we're going is that the trail oh this is
the trail i think i double dare i double dare you to get off
the trail okay your turn your turn We're not going up there.
No, you got to say true for dare.
Look at this place.
Look at all of this.
Your turn.
That leads to a bed and breakfast.
True for dare.
No, we've never heard of.
In a town we've never heard of.
Well, I triple dare double dare you.
They get off the trail again.
Ah!
Listen, that lady's safe.
Guys, she's crazy.
I don't know that.
Harry, I don't know any of you.
Wait, there's an invisible wall.
Why?
Wait, we forgot to get the suitcase.
Oh, yeah, our suitcase!
Oh!
Why didn't they tell us that before?
You're seriously fine with us?
Two strangers we just met, pointing us down a dark trail,
and you're just...
You're fine.
You're chill.
We're chill.
We're pretty chill.
Okay, I hold the flashlight.
You hold the...
You just never want to look for...
Wait, do I need mine?
No.
Okay, we're good.
It means you just decide and expect everyone to follow.
Oh my god, they're fighting.
This is...
We need to...
What's happening to us?
Hold on.
Is this about last night?
What happened last night?
What happened?
I thought last night was a maze balls.
The job, the apartment, your studio, all of it.
Oh.
What is my job?
I did find it.
And I am moving to Washington.
Tessa.
I wasn't even there.
Like, this was something you were doing.
And I just happened to be coming along.
Whoa.
We're fighting in the dark woods.
This is crazy.
I don't want to feel like I'm along the way.
I dare you to go off the trail.
That's all I'm asking.
I didn't even realize that it was such a big deal.
I thought everyone was laughing.
And so were you.
Oh my god.
She's doing it.
wouldn't you're not along for the ride and stop making
decisions like i am i hear you okay i hear you but right now
you need to make a decision like how she wants to argue in
the forest at the middle of the night right like this could
have been like in the the what was it the breakfast bed and
breakfast place i know right we're just doing it in the
middle of the woods get the suitcase I'm running ahead.
I'm running ahead.
On paper, things look pretty bleak for us.
I know.
A relationship.
Yum.
Crumbling.
But the only help in town was the stay up the hill.
Oh.
Let's die.
I dare you to go pet him.
Where is he?
Let's go.
Let's go get him.
Alright.
I don't think... I think he's up the hill, isn't he?
Oh, there's an invisible wall.
It won't even let you there's like no doggo for you it
sounds like a man trying to be a dog sounds
like a box like oh i'm on top of you wait can i hit your
ride can i keep going oh dang it all right what's that say
scrap i'm sorry about last night i didn't think about how
that sounded yeah my feelings look we are going to
washington does that make you feel better now we we are
going to washington but i i'm the one that got the new job
though wait what if i do you think it'll break
wait wait wait a minute get out oh oh throw it in the water
go get it go get it
Oh, it's right here, it's right here, it's right here.
Aw, man.
What if there was like a little troll under here?
Hey, the troll.
Hey, Dev.
A funny idea.
That was one of those soft lockers.
Right?
It's like you see the luggage slowly drift along the river.
See that?
no there was a deer oh it ran past and this is a two-hour
game we're almost done we're almost done maybe probably who
knows oh fade to black yeah we're extending our play time
because we're having so much fun you guys 10 p.m.
Power.
Can we make it?
Oh, am I holding my luggage?
I am still holding the luggage.
Yeah, we got this.
Keep going!
Oh, we made it.
Oh, there's a light!
I see the light!
The old house sat on the other side of the road.
I'm not gonna look both ways.
I'm just gonna run.
There is a car heading over.
Wait, what if?
I could get insurance right now.
Yeah, yeah.
The payout would be great.
with us clean beds hot meals no vacancy elsewhere oh oh okay
wait this place does look way bigger than expected private
property no trespassing no we're customers we're customers
that's true that's true we're not trespassing guys no no no
deserve to be here all right let us in the environment i'm
gonna let you knock first okay okay bed and breakfast oh i
got a text message too okay yeah
knock Charlotte called ahead such a sweet woman isn't she
uh-huh uh-huh you poor things car giving you trouble on a
night like this I know oh she's so nice come on come on
mercy me I got she doesn't seem racist so I can come and
come in are you too hungry yes you look like yes we are I'm
starving No, we're okay.
What?
We're so hungry.
I'm so hungry.
You don't speak.
We just had a conversation about how you don't speak for
both of us.
Okay, shut it, can't you?
Marcus, this is Tessa.
Tessa, what a lovely name.
You're going to feel right at home here, my dear.
Does not acknowledge you?
Yeah, hello?
Are you alone?
Why would you ask that?
I'm just kidding.
How do you run this place by yourself?
Oh, yeah.
Could you imagine me here all alone?
I've got a few hired hands.
Folks from the church also check in.
Oh.
How much for a room?
From the church.
Depends on how long you'd be staying.
Only one night.
Oh my gosh, what's that?
What's that?
For the night, it's night at 5.
Breakfast at 5.
Ninety-five!
But don't you worry about that now, sweetheart.
This is without inflation!
We'll square away payment in the morning.
What the fuck?
can we get our room could we get to our room please why did
you leave my dining prices i know that's crazy it's because
she has a monopoly on the place i'll go check oh my gosh you
guys remember she has no vacancy elsewhere yeah um excuse me
is there a restroom i could use yeah it's in the back by the
kitchen i know she doesn't even look at me i know she
doesn't even look at me oh i had to I have to pee.
Bye.
No, it won't let me.
Have fun.
Wait, are you not allowed inside?
No, I can't go in.
No pee for you.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Also, this area is actually pretty spooky.
Okay, have fun.
There's a bunch of religious statues everywhere.
Oh, have fun.
Yeah, there's a Virgin Mary.
And then on the side, there's like this.
Yeah, no, this room sucks.
Have fun.
go sit down and play chess or something.
I feel like I'm going to get jump scared though.
I feel like something's going to happen.
To me.
No pee-pee for me.
What about...
Don't... Ah!
What the?
What?
Don't even say anything.
I'm leaving.
You all should be ashamed of yourselves.
Excuse me?
Who am Hi, who are you?
Tell that crazy old bitch upstairs that I'm gone.
Whatever you people are doing here, I want no parts.
Um, oh my god.
Who are you?
What they say?
What?
What do you say?
Wait, what do you say?
I think they might be, I think they might be cannibals.
Two hour and 34 minutes and 57 seconds.
it has been zero days since cannibalism has been mentioned
on my channel wait no i had a guy run out of the door and he
was like if you're whatever you guys are doing in here i
want no part of it i went ahead and put you in our majestic
suite oh you talk before i take you talk countless every day
deeper respect for this majestic house anyway so when I was
peeing they're like they sure I take they sure look tasty
and I'm like oh yeah this guy he came running down and he
was just like he was like you should be ashamed of yourself
whatever you guys are doing here I want no part of it and
just ran out well let's Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, what's over here?
This is our Parsons study.
Oh, I thought she was bleeding.
Yeah, yeah, that's the, that's, see, this is what I mean.
Look at that creepy statue on the right.
Oh, that's scary.
Yeah.
Oh, that was, I thought that was a person.
We got history older than anything, my dears.
Feel free to browse the shells if you'd like a good read.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, so what was your last cannibalism conversation,
Min?
to explain.
I don't know.
I'm sure somebody has time stamped it though.
Why don't you have the lights?
That thing scares me every time.
This place is old and that includes the pipes.
The pipes.
Not to drink from the taps.
Yep.
And remember this is not...
Oh, don't drink the water.
Don't drink the water.
It's probably drugged.
It's time to get you two cents.
Wait, did you drink the water?
No, I... Did you?
I want to drink the water.
Did you cough or did she?
She coughed.
You're drinking this patient zero.
Are you drinking rum?
What are you doing?
What's going on?
I taste the black.
What is this drinking?
Okay, I'm done.
I told you not to do that.
I told you not to do.
Okay, I'll drink the water, too.
What's that?
Oh, it's the bathroom.
Oh.
You washed your hands, right?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah.
Of course I did.
Oh my god, do you still have your funky autocrats?
No, that was just, that was all me and that was all me.
No, yeah, all you.
Get our suitcase.
Alright, suitcase is here.
Read.
Thank you for choosing to stay at Old Scratch Temple's
parsonage.
This house has stood in service of the temple for
generations and we take great pride in its history.
Kindly sign your name and leave a note about your stay.
It is the rule of the house and a tradition we have kept
since the earliest days.
Thank you for honoring our customs and the legacy of Old
Scratch Temple.
Gratitudes, gratuities, gratuities for Bobby and Henry are
appreciated.
Miss Julia.
Janice said, warm bed and cozy blankets.
This house settles a lot at night.
Thought someone was walking up the stairs at night, but
never saw anyone.
Overall, a pleasant stay.
Grateful for the shelter and the closeness.
everywhere will hold watch after dark you do may he bless
you said brother l bless you evan and claire question mark
road trip stop beautiful woods claire says the church made
her uncomfortable i thought it was quaint and delightful
we'll recommend you to friends stayed the night before the
meeting everything is ready the morning star watches over
you how many it well i stayed here there's a lot of pages
heard the bell at 3 27 a.m no one else did that's how i know
it's still listening oh my god there's so many pages there's
so many pages i'm sure all these people were fine i'm sure
i'm sure they're all okay now yeah how do i come on tessa we
gotta go to our room i'm Me too, I'm coming, I'm coming.
This is the bathroom, I don't see any lights though.
Love you daddy.
Alright, let's...
We're in the suite though.
Oh.
Yeah, well I don't know if there's any ghosts in the
bathroom.
No.
Okay, it was locked.
That's locked.
Oh my god.
Not needed.
Oh,
is this our room?
Oh, she's in there.
Wait, who's down here?
Well, go here.
Yeah, I was going to sit.
No one.
Oh, we can look through the window.
Oh, we can.
All right, let's go inside.
All right, now I'm going to just...
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
What was he doing here?
Comfortable temperature.
So you shouldn't feel a chill tonight.
Oh, put in extra effort.
this evening to prepare for your arrival so i hope
everything meets your expectations miss julia and if you
need anything at all press zero on the telephone okay we ask
forters to reserve late night calls for emergencies only
okay okay we'll call if we need anything yeah we'll call if
we need to wait i can't even talk to her she doesn't even
give me an option to talk to her I'll leave you two to it.
No way.
You know when both of us have options to do dialogue?
Ew, she's kicking me out of the room.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Oh, and let's behave ourselves tonight, all right?
Oh, kitchen fights.
I didn't notice any rings, so we've made sure there are
separate beds for each of you.
Folks at Old Scratch Temple like to make sure people keep
themselves pure.
Oh, it's that type of church.
Oh, wait.
Don't worry.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good then.
Oh, sorry.
Do you mind if we get the room key?
Oh, sweetie.
I'm afraid a house this old doesn't have key.
What?
That's not even that's...
I don't know.
The door locks itself.
I don't believe that.
But if you both...
How do you get in then?
How do you get in?
Oh, skeleton.
Oh.
We do charge $20 for the trip.
What?
Happens more than you'd think.
So figured I'd mention the charge.
skeleton key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would like that.
I can't give you the skeleton key.
It unlocks every door in the house.
But it says $28.
I thought that you two would go snooze.
So like $28 per like unlock?
Yeah, I think so.
If you get locked out, which means we just have to keep the
door open all the time.
Well, it locks itself.
So you would seem to like it won't.
Okay, maybe you're right.
Oh, we got, do you want to sign the guest book?
Wait, before we go, I want to watch TV.
Oh, yeah, I want to see Kitchen Nightmares.
You know, me too.
Wait, oh my gosh, Breaking Bad is on!
You just closed the door on here?
We were both super exhausted.
I thought these people came here to help my restaurant out,
not make fun of it.
They told me to brush my teeth.
Such a shame.
Are you going to go sign the guest book?
No.
watch TV.
Leslie, wake up!
Yeah, Leslie.
What the hell?
Leslie, take your hand off the flame.
It's on fire.
Why?
Oh my god, Leslie, no!
I thought you were done with the drink.
Okay, I'll go.
I'll go.
Wait, wait, wait.
You're missing a good part!
Wait, you're there missing a good part!
Oh!
That's Morgan!
It's over.
I think...
I think I need a bath.
I feel disgusting after that.
The fish has taken over the factory.
I'm going to get a bath.
You go sign the guest book.
Oh, I got a message from dad.
Go sign it.
I waited.
Oh, the water's done.
I'm in.
Ooh, little duckie.
Are you having a bath?
Yeah?
Are you knocking?
I realized the bathroom did not have any towels.
I'm trying to relax!
Finally, she's tucked him back.
This is kind of ASMR.
are.
Oh, is
he gonna walk down there?
Everybody plays cows in the bath.
Oh
my god!
Go, Doki!
Go,
get me a towel!
No!
Give me a towel.
I'm going to drown myself.
I hate my dad.
And I can't get...
Oh, wait.
I can get out.
I didn't have any towels.
I'm peeing.
Please give me a towel.
Wow.
I really...
Can you hear that?
Come on, I'm gonna pee again.
I didn't have to pee anymore.
Oh no.
Toki, please!
Go give me a towel!
Oh!
Go!
Give me it down!
I feel like this is how it would be actually roving with
Stokia.
Oh.
I'm gonna escape.
I'm gonna escape through.
Yes!
I'm gonna become the Joker.
I'm gonna...
Whoa, look at the church!
Wait, that's crazy!
Power, go get your powers!
Whoa.
Red means scary.
Wait, are those people?
Go!
Are those people right there?
You think those are people?
Doki?
Very eerie.
Yeah, I can't tell if people are bushes.
They're staring.
Wait.
I just heard.
Towel.
I heard her phone go off.
Long cutscene.
What does that mean?
She's talking a lot.
Then how are you texting?
I'm not.
not driving what does that mean i want out of the bathroom i
want out of the bathroom i'm trapped here i'm trapped also
wait i'll take this time to figure out how to stick how do i
get rid of the items i've been holding this entire time wait
how do i uh uh oh i found it okay hold on oh that's it Oh!
Oh!
And then my knife.
You missed the melon!
Wait, wait, I'm holding too many things now, you guys.
I don't know what I'm holding.
I'm holding too many things.
Wait, I don't know what I'm holding.
Wait, I kind of want the crowbar, though.
Or double knives.
Let's do double knives.
Okay.
And I'm also gonna...
I can't proceed the cutscene because I don't know if you
need pickles.
Oh.
Yes.
I always want pickles.
Wait, what did I just open up?
Hopefully nothing.
Oh, well, I shouldn't scoot back over because we still got
the she says okay
this is the only thing i can do for fun oh no wait i have
cows so pickles and towels yeah oh wait hold on that was not
in the game that was me for the first time in the history of
the show
90 acres fiat open the door
i'm quitting this game i'm going to i'm going to all f4
right now i'm going to i will alt f4 in the game
um why are you trying to open my door go get the towel and
open come
Oh, oh
What Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, she hasn't been doing
anything this entire time.
Oh my god Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
I I didn't notice but I give you the call I give you the
call for towers
Right, I understand but I'm gonna go get my dinner so that I
am not up until 5 a.m.
Packing my fucking shit!
I don't
mess up.
Why am I not going to go get it?
Why am I doing all this food stuff?
If you head out to the back door to the church, then go down
to the food show.
This is probably going to be watching my food show.
This is what I wanted me time.
Well then, if you'll excuse me, it's a...
Look, I have to go to the basement, man.
Man, I'm gonna go to the basement now.
I'll be back in five minutes.
Ooh, can you hear me?
Yeah?
I gotta go downstairs to grab a towel.
I'll be right back.
Right now?
She said everyone's asleep.
It's the only option.
Just...
Don't worry about it.
I'll air dry.
Please be safe.
I'll leave the TV on first.
No way!
I booze!
Hello?
Doki?
she's lost downstairs she went to go get towels did she now
did she did she really what the fuck am I supposed to be
doing in here
she went into a spooky basement serves her right I'm gonna
sit here warm and calm and relaxed with my flashlight
I'm sitting on the toilet.
Yeah, I'm going to click cows even.
Greatest gameplay of all time.
Yeah, I don't know if the dev thought about this one.
What I get for dinner?
I got this like...
It's like a fruit bowl, but it's from a place that I really
like that is not where I'm going to be moving, so it's my
last time having it.
Wee!
Doki doesn't even know that you can't.
Yes, she does!
She has to know!
Yeah,
a cow clicker.
Maybe that's why they put it on here.
Wait, let's see if my friend Ellie will talk to me.
Be safe!
I know!
At this point, I'm completely dry.
I'm just air-dried.
Actually, I like air-dried.
I like getting out of a shower and then just being like
Towels are for for fools You can still text Doki.
Oh, you're so right
Did you get my towels yet?
I'm at a church.
Wait, I just heard a door knock.
Someone was at the door.
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
I left the TV on for you.
Someone is here.
Swagless nerd!
Nice.
Now I can watch TV.
You are his son!
No!
Yay!
I told you, I told you he was my son.
I told him he was my son.
That's just a photo of me.
Actually, that's a TV.
You took the only flashlight so I can't see.
Boohoo.
Get good.
Wait, so you used to look like that and now you look like
this.
Does that mean?
Yep.
It'll happen to you too, son.
No!
When we return, we're gonna meet Brittany, who wants to
confront her brother, constantly misusing the words.
We'll be back after these short messages.
I'm gonna look through.
Stop it.
Ew!
I'm gonna hide.
Will it let me hide?
Maybe I open the door.
The all new pickle leprechaun.
How many things did they make for this TV?
Like how many ads?
Programs I guess.
I never wanna be in there again.
Oh my God, what?
Oh.
The best part is their cheat.
Hello.
Less than the cost of a bite.
Miss?
Yes?
Uh...
Open the door?
I let Henry into the room.
Wait, I didn't let- Take a second.
Oh, he's gotta give me towels?
Wait, why'd you shut the door?
What do you mean you're in the bathroom?
Are you using our bathroom?
Hello?
What are we doing?
He's retrieving the camera.
oh my god she's so needy they locked me in the basement
please come to the church can you ask for help no can you
ask for help i'm gonna sleep i don't know if you saw that
but i just threw the uh the flashlight over there
i'm going to sleep
ZZZZ.
Oh yeah, we might want to lock the door.
So true.
It's probably locked.
I think it's locked.
Yeah, it's locked.
Actually, I'm kind of shocked at like, it's not being like,
oh my god, where's Marcus?
You know?
Oh, I can call too.
Hello?
Doki's going through it right now.
Good.
Oh, the bathroom.
So true.
They hung up on me!
Yeah, what are you doing here?
They give me towels?
That's...
There were still no towels!
Oh my god!
I lost.
What was that?
He drank the bathwater.
Alienated at first sight.
What's your favorite song?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, I was done with.
Oh, maybe I call again for more towels.
Excuse me?
She can't text me anymore.
Hello?
Get on cow.
Hop on cow.
anyway besides it was super cute yeah it's time to meet the
bride's parents what am i supposed to do like i don't
actually know what i'm supposed to do leave oh we'll cut
that out come closer to the camera oh i want a close-up of
their faces it like won't let me leave oh wait will the
mother give her permission oh i guess i can but i'm naked oh
no it won't let me leave did you record that will you send
it to me later that was incredible actually i have no idea
what i'm supposed to do uh do i leave the window is locked
no not anymore i'm naked and afraid what am i supposed to do
doki had this problem got to try a few times oh really
Cincinnati ohio where an old couple has begun to notice that
customers are starting to Oh.
This kitchen is broken.
Every health code in the book.
I don't say anything wrong with it.
What is she doing anyway?
What's going on with her?
Find some clothes?
Oh my god.
I just noticed the eyeball.
What the heck?
What is this the decoration?
Don't get the call first.
I tried.
I didn't pick up.
Hello?
Oh, see, they hung up on me.
Go look under the window.
I tried.
Oh, I heard her phone.
I just heard her phone.
Doki.
Hop on cow.
I had no reception.
There are coffins.
I'm going to bed.
There's someone under it.
Wait.
The window in the bathroom?
I didn't see anything.
Nothing there.
I honestly have no idea what to do.
The game is...
The game is not very clear on what I'm supposed to do here.
What is that?
Oh, that's the guy, isn't it?
Hello?
Oh, he's gone.
Doki got jump scared?
Oh, what happened?
I got jump scare.
But I would.
This is like so for your stupid towels.
Wait, what if I hide?
And then I jump scare her too.
Oh, I can't.
Stop jorking it in front of my door.
Not interested.
I can't hear you over the sound of my Honda.
Okay.
It was Harry.
Who's Harry?
Wait, he was supposed to come give me towels.
Also, what the hell?
This was so boring for me.
You texted me.
I would gladly swap places with you.
I had to go to the creepy ass church.
Go to the basement for your fuck towels and I got locked
out.
So...
He's laughing about it.
Find the towels.
Yeah, let me put them in the bathroom.
Alright, I got you your towels.
Wait, but Harry...
How on the floor you get to watch TV?
Was that show not entertaining?
I had a fun time.
Nah.
It's kind of mid.
Go put it on the way to the towels.
Where do I put the towels?
Probably here.
Am I?
No.
Where the fuck do I put the towel?
Oh, here, maybe?
Oh, maybe?
Oh, maybe up here?
Oh, no, that's...
We can lock it.
and down there i think i was watching him waiting for you to
jump oh wait in here in here and here maybe okay yeah boo
boo a guy came up here while you were gone who came up harry
came up yeah i don't know one of the workers or something
and he just that was not wait why are we coughing just like
the lady open the door oh yeah i did because i i thought
Julia sent him here or something, but he actually didn't
have towels.
That's not true.
I got jump scared.
It's fucking weird, boo.
Miss Julia.
That's not true.
Oh, man.
Miss Julia didn't say anything.
Everybody kept hanging up the phone for me.
I forgot to sign the guest book she asked.
Oh, yeah, I could see.
It was like calling Miss Julia.
I saw you try to call her like five times.
Okay.
I'll go sign it real quick.
Is that not it?
I put, do you have to click it?
I think my throat's acting up.
Oh, I found it.
Wow.
a cold again i can go get it no i'm what are you doing
putting on my towel wait have i not been naked you just got
out of the bath don't you are not making me freshen up no
see that's so weird i was like what are we supposed to do
you sure i got it i'm coughing just like the lady i'm sick
in the head i'm sick in the head wait you just sniffed are
we both sick i think so we drank the water we drink we have
to sleep we have to sleep now oh you don't even take a bag
of I would have gotten you a towel so you're not even gonna
take a bath.
Do you know my trauma?
I'm gonna sit here and do this the entire night while you
fucking sleep.
You will never know happiness.
Oh my god, epilepsy warning.
Epilepsy warning.
I'm not calling police.
She's trying to make me epileptic.
Good.
Seize.
I hope you seize.
Oh, now you want to progress the game.
Now you want to progress.
No, I want to listen to TV on a full blast.
I don't want to do anything.
I was locked out.
I was locked out just like you are.
No, no.
I was locked in.
I was locked in that damn bathroom for like 20 fucking
minutes while you iPad baby on the TV.
I really told you.
I really told you I had a cutscene with Miss Julia.
I don't believe you.
I had a cutscene with Miss Julia.
No, it's not my fault.
I'm going to sleep.
I don't want to talk about it.
Marcus, you liar.
I don't think we're supposed to go to sleep.
I don't know.
What are we supposed to do?
We need gamer paint.
We need like a little objective in the corner.
I'll close the door.
Wait, what?
What?
Don't turn that on.
Go take your bath.
I'll close the door.
Wait, am I finally?
I was in the bath though.
Wait, what am I doing?
Oh!
We gotta go sign the guest book.
Oh my god.
The fucking guest book.
All right.
Go and lock the door Wait, come on Wait, I'm stuck I can't
actually Wait, I'm stuck Okay, okay Oh my god Oh my god Okay
All right, come on Okay Wait, I can't Oh, you are I have to
go do it I have to go do it alone I realize I shouldn't have
left the door open Okay, bye Okay, okay Goodbye
Oh my god Oh Oh my god.
Only one at a time.
It's fine.
I'll sign the guest book.
I'll make it really nice and pretty.
What does Marcus want?
You're missing out on our favorite show.
I have no favorites.
How do I sign it?
Oh, here.
Oh, wow.
Oh, um, what's today?
June?
Oh, tent?
Oh.
Ah,
let's see.
It was a night like another.
Marcus, behind the wheel.
And also me, behind the wheel.
A crash.
A bang.
We ran into another wall.
And another car.
But neither of us could expect the car to break down.
Enter Julia.
No, Charlotte.
A humble bed and breakfast.
Destination.
Comfort.
We...
we uh mose how do you spell mosey
we how do you spell moseed uh now i'll just say we mosey
along a dark and dreary a wooded path i almost wrote bath
because of my trauma moseed it's okay we're in first purse
oh Oh, Doki's still here.
Sorry.
My computer is, like, flipping out, you guys.
I hope the stream is okay.
Is the stream good?
Is RU here good?
This chat is pretty split on Mosey to Mosey.
Moosey.
It's good?
Okay, good.
Um, our drama, dramatic.
My feelings?
Dramatic.
But the...
But the bread...
Wait, no.
Bed and breakfast?
Two out of ten.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Locked in the bathroom.
And that is my novel, Locked in the Bathroom.
I don't think I can go anymore.
This is my favorite stream this year.
We have to laugh this hard at age.
just two out of ten locked in the bathroom oh can you live
tweet there's someone breaking into our room right now come
back quick someone outside the door be careful I think he
has a weapon I look through the hole I think we're about to
get jump scared perhaps maybe hmm I finished my fanfic wait
what just
happened hello Hello?
Hello?
Is she dead?
Do you see him?
Oh, I haven't gone.
Oop.
I'm gonna get you up scared.
Ah!
I needed to get some water.
Oh.
I need water.
She opened the door?
There's no guy.
Where would he go?
even go oh oh it won't let me up it's forcing me to drink
the yeah the drink that i'm gonna urges to eat people the
urges grow strong gosh these i need to get some water from
the cooler in the back yeah what she want the guy is back
i'm getting water i'm thirsty
I'm drinking.
I'm gonna get jump scared.
Oh, I drank water from the cooler.
I was feeling pretty tired.
Why is this open?
Is this the way she went?
Oh gosh, I knew it.
I knew it.
Hello?
Up late, dear?
Oh.
I needed water.
Sorry, I just needed some water.
My throat.
Your young man, a little while ago.
What was he doing down there?
Down where?
Down under.
Oh, you know where, sweetie.
What?
Bobby saw him.
I know nothing.
Did I not specifically tell you both when we came in?
That door stays closed?
Oh, she won't let me move.
Towards her.
I don't think he won't let me choke her neck.
He just went to get towels.
I told him the church basement, where the laundry is, not
this basement.
Uh-uh.
Hmm.
Miss Julia, you're a little strange.
Big day tomorrow.
What's so big about it?
What's so big about it, huh, Miss Julia?
Oh, take it.
For someone renting a guest house, she felt like...
more hostile than hospitable big day i just jump scared my
cat i couldn't shake the feeling that something about the
place was very wrong i think you're very right about that i
think anybody with any intuition would be able to know oh
what doki say did you get your water did you see the guy
julia
is he here wait let's see is he still there
I want her to tell me before I look.
I think he left.
Is he gonna jump out of the bathroom?
No, thank you.
Is this my room?
Which is my room?
Hello?
Which one's my room?
Oh.
Oh my god.
You didn't lock the door?
Okay.
Doki, are you trying to jump scare me?
Hello?
Boo.
Oh, what the hell?
You were gone a while.
Mr. Julia stopped me downstairs.
I thought literally what I tried doing earlier.
Marcus, someone saw you coming up.
Yeah, I pulled.
Yeah, but I pulled it through.
Okay, sure.
That's all you have to say.
Where was he?
What was he?
What did he look like?
What do you want me to say?
He just he looked like a man.
Why?
Because I stood there and covered for you and I don't even
know what I'm covering for.
Why are we?
Yeah, why'd you go into the basement?
Huh?
She got mad at me.
Oh.
This one was connected to the church basement.
I got locked in there and ended up coming back through the
wrong side.
A tunnel?
Yeah, it was like filled with coffins and stuff.
But why?
I don't know.
I didn't build it.
It's an old building.
Tessa finally said she thinks something's weird.
How did she even get locked in there in the first place?
Now she thinks something's weird.
Yeah, yeah.
After everything.
That's fucking weird.
And what's also weird is you didn't think to tell me any of
this.
Okay, okay.
I just didn't want to freak you out.
For no reason.
That's like this.
Doing that.
What?
Stop making decisions for the two of us.
Are you serious right now?
I'm just trying to protect you, boo.
What did you want me to do, Tess?
Come back up here and tell you about a secret tunnel season.
You're trying to steal my shit?
With no car?
You've already been on the edge for no reason this whole
time.
Maybe stop reading into things and just let me handle it.
Yeah!
Let me handle it.
I'm the man of the house.
That's right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sure.
You handle it.
Hey.
I'm just gonna watch TV from now on.
I'm going to bed.
You want me to try a TV?
Mm-hmm.
Alright, we can go watch TV while we sleep.
Also, why is the TV facing that side?
You wouldn't think it'd be on...
Over here in the center.
There's no room for it though.
I'm going to sleep.
Of course you want me closest to the door, you know?
Good night.
Yep.
You snooze, you lose.
Okay.
Alright.
I love you.
good night yeah good night i like how this guy has literally
no worries ever you okay you didn't even say i love you back
i think she's reconsidering everything 3 33 i am oh my god i
woke up with a dry
is she in dreamland what's going on in wait what's going on
in her pov
oh what's going on in her pov i need to know
wait where are oh our flashlights
she's getting sleep paralysis i'll help her out
i would rather be in her pov i'm I realized I shouldn't have
left the door open.
My bad.
I had to get water from downstairs.
More water.
Nightmare, nightmare, nightmare.
Alan Wakeland?
Oh, she can hear me?
I'm getting water.
Oh my god, the statues scared me.
I had to get water from downstairs.
Okay, my god, I'm going.
I'm getting the water.
I'm thirsty.
What's going on?
I'm getting water.
I think I'm gonna get eaten.
Oh, what's happening?
Someone's at the door!
The bitch got away.
Then you were too slow.
Yeah.
Or maybe you slipped.
Don't you dare speak to me that way.
Let the morning star burn you where you stand.
He'll burn you.
Oh.
Wait, I died?
Responding without alerting the other survivor.
What?
Oh my god, are you kidding me right now?
What am I supposed to do?
I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit, but it's hard to
hear them.
Oh, that guy that escaped.
We needed him.
We have another.
Uh-oh.
Sorry that I'm hiding the subtype.
Hold on.
Let me move a little.
I'll move, Doki.
I think they're still talking, though.
Wait, one second.
Sorry.
Okay.
I no longer felt tired.
My gut told me to check on Marcus as soon as possible.
Marcos?
Okay!
Oh, this is finally closed.
Someone's using the bathroom.
What was that?
You good?
Wait, who was that?
Responding because the other survivor died.
Sequence for other survivors still underway.
Please wait for them.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Uh, I can't go still.
Uh.
Oh.
Where are you?
finish your job
I can't you died and it respawned me he's not leaving the
room oh other survivor sequence is now done oh whoops how
did you die you died you died You think the guy's gonna, is
he gonna scream again?
Ah!
Boo, I need to tell you something.
Boo!
He's coming.
Marcus was not a light sleeper.
He's in the room.
Oh.
What am I supposed to do?
I tried opening, but.
We need to go right now.
What?
Get out, go, go, go.
We have to go.
We have, he left.
We have to go, we have.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
to go let's go how did you die how did you die uh she
stabbed me she stabbed me okay okay we got it oh i think we
got it red red red oh
no okay come on come on come on okay let's try it let's try
the door by the water get out go go yeah yeah yeah yeah
kitchen right kitchen yeah yeah yeah go Go, go, go, go, go,
go, go.
Kitchen by the kitchen.
Oh my god, I don't have a flashlight, so it's like...
So disorienting.
Oh my god.
Ah!
I got pushed into him!
Go
to the tunnels?
Okay, okay, leave me to the tunnel.
We need to go.
Go, go, go.
Wait, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Don't push me, don't push me!
follow you i'm gonna follow you follow me follow me
oh hold on wait one second one second i gripped my headphone
cord out
hello we need to go right now get out go go go go wait there
should be there should be no i wait come in here come in
here what if he comes back no there's no other flashlight
just you only have oh do you want it do you want it yeah
yeah yeah there you go all right all right i know where to
go okay all right let's go i'm following you all right
follow me oh my god i hate that it does that all right it's
the store it's the store oh my god no it's not it's not that
door it's not the store it's not this door it's not this
door it's not this door and we go to the church we go to the
I'm following you!
If I get caught, it's your fault!
Why are we going to the church?
That's where they all go!
Okay.
Ah!
Not that...
Okay, not the church, everybody.
Not the church.
It's not the church.
Oh, I have to right now.
Yeah, yeah.
I think we gotta go to the...
What if we go to the basement?
basement what get out go go go oh i remember where it is i'm
going to the wrong door i remember i chose the wrong door i
remember the actual door oh my god oh my god okay okay go go
go basement why i've never been here before oh my god did
you just shut the door on me Wait, it's locked!
Locked!
This section took my friend 20 minutes, so gosh.
Wait, wait, wait!
The coffin?
Okay.
What if we need to go?
Play dead, play dead.
Dude, dude, dude, dude.
That's what the coffin means!
Oh shit, oh shit.
Here!
Oh!
There we go.
Shh!
No, you had the flashlight.
We need to go right now.
Go.
Get out.
Oh my god.
Wait, we can't see it all.
Okay, okay, this time, this time, we got it.
We got this.
Don't talk.
Don't talk!
They came this way
Do we run?
Alright, uh, where do we go?
Do we, I think we go the same way that we came from, right?
And then, because they went the opposite way.
The thing is, we don't have a flashlight anymore.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
I can't see.
Oh.
Doki?
Where am I going?
What just happened?
Why did she run the other way?
Why did she go?
She went for... Why did she go for the church?
Why did you... Oh my god.
Why did you go to the church?
I was...
I was almost out.
What?
Get out.
Go, go, go.
I was never meant for my sins.
Oh my god, why did it put us all the way back here?
Oh my god!
Why did you leave through the front door?
Why did you go to the church?
They came this way!
I'm playing cows.
Get out of that fucking coffin.
I tried texting you, but it said no signal.
Oh, no signal.
Yeah, yeah, that was me when I was in the basement.
Okay, this time, go to the front door.
I follow you.
Yeah, yeah, okay, I'll follow you this time.
This is what you should have done the first fucking time.
I got scared.
I wish we had a flashlight, though.
It's actually hard to see.
I know, what happened to our flashlight?
I don't know.
Are you there?
I'm behind you.
Okay.
We're running.
Where's the gate?
Is this it?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know where to go from here.
Through the woods again.
Oh, my God.
I can't see anything.
Oh!
Oh, did we do it?
Did we do it?
did we do it oh what's going good oh why is it oh our car oh
it's that's where our car is yeah it's our bed and the the
bill oh what's that oh it's what's his name what do we do
what the guy the guy that was supposed to fix our cars there
he might kill us i think he's got a gun yes yes
Wait, we could take their car.
We could take their car.
Yeah, we could take their car.
What's the news?
This is Get Out.
I told you this is Get Out.
That's the movie.
You learned me in here.
It's just like the movie.
You literally, my brain's in me.
Someone else's body.
I just wanted some pie at the old bed and breakfast.
I keep saying bread and breakfast.
Oh wait, if we crouch, what if we walk?
And crouch, walk to the car and take it.
Let's just try.
Where are you?
Oh.
Oops.
It was not it.
That was not it.
I was wrong.
What if we run to the car?
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to listen to the dialogue.
How was I supposed to know that?
I'm pretty sure.
He was like, Billy boy.
It's fine.
We're back here.
All right.
We're back to listening to the dialogue.
Billy boy.
A Billy boy.
Where is he?
Do you see him?
He's like walking out.
Yeah.
I don't see him.
Wait, I don't see him.
Wait, did he respawn?
Because he killed you?
Wait, do you see him?
No, what do you see?
Wait, we can skip the dialogue!
Okay, I'm skipping.
Okay, we skip?
Yeah.
Wait, is he talking?
Something about the first time it'll be the last time?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do we do?
He's looking.
Is he coming out here?
Oh, is he looking at us?
Oh, look, he's turning around.
Should we go?
Yeah, I think so.
You first.
Me first, why?
Yes, you first.
Wait, what if he just leaves?
I don't think so.
Which way, which, where, do we take our car?
But it doesn't move.
I think we take their car, remember?
Which one is theirs?
A truck?
Oh.
I think when he turns around, the music goes.
Okay.
I think when he turns around, we go.
Yeah, yeah, let's go.
Okay, good.
All right.
Do we get in our car?
Oh, shit.
Oh god!
Maybe we run.
Maybe we don't have to sneak.
Do you think?
It's time to skip the dialogue.
Yeah, skip the dialogue.
You're still crouched.
I was in front of you.
You go to the front.
Where are you?
Oh.
Wait, is he...
What?
Are they talking?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
He's right in front of us.
Wait, what's happening?
He's glitched.
Wait, you see that.
I see the car.
Yeah, I see the car.
Oh.
I said I'm coming.
Oh, okay.
You skipped it?
Okay, good.
First time.
Luckily won't be the way.
Luckily won't be.
Wait, isn't that the guy that owns the gas station?
No, no.
That's the different guy.
No, I'm pretty sure the guy that is with the gas station.
the question marks what he can't hear us that's fine i'm
gonna yell at him hi don't you own the gas station see okay
okay i'm ready wait not yet are we trying for his car i
think we should try for hours i'm pretty sure we are we okay
yeah i'm going for our car
i'm getting in the driver's seat
Oh, fuck.
The trailer is too heavy.
The trailer, oh my god.
It's fine.
We didn't know that we didn't need the trailer.
Now we know we have to get rid of the trailer.
You drive then, you drive.
Okay, you do the, you do the trailer.
What?
I get in the car.
No, why do I have to do the trailer?
because you you hugged you hugged the car
okay okay where is he oh he's he's leaving the porch
okay not yet okay okay go how do i do this go
go go go go
He's pushing the car.
Yes, he's right behind us.
Close your door.
Don't he close the door.
He's the one pushing us.
Uh, what
do we do?
Reverse it, reverse it.
I die.
Oh my god.
I might have actually hit the tree.
No, I noticed.
I noticed.
Yeah.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
Do we get our car?
Oh my god.
Are you skip the dialogue again?
I think you have to just drive and ignore him.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, your turn.
Your turn to drive.
Oh my god.
We take turns until it works.
You get the trailer then.
All right.
Need to be.
first time yeah two hour game oh my gosh i'm gonna be up
until five in the morning tonight i thought this was gonna
be so fast oh
not yet
why is the radio on because i turned it on okay get in all
right how do i see oh Ah, fuck.
He's right there.
Why does it do this?
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Oh, why?
Why does it do this?
Why?
when does it start getting faster oh is he on
us is he behind us oh we made it oh my god i'm turning it
down sorry we barely made it back to the main road before
the car gave out again i felt as though they were still
behind us we called the cops and waited by the road they
took us to the station for the report and left and
investigate the area immediately we did not find anything
incriminating was all we heard from them marcus suggested we
go back and confront them ourselves but i realized it was
wise to let go as the sheriff didn't dismiss us or call as
crazy he listened more than i expected which creeped me out
even more at first i didn't connect the night to jack's
story but something makes me makes me believe those people
were somehow involved oh my god it's still playing oh i just
turned it off other survivor is still reading yeah why would
you confront them they literally tried to murder you
I want the new Oh my god
She's still reading No, it said you were still reading No,
it said you were still reading I was looking at that text Me
too, me too Me too I was looking at that text I was looking
at it first, I promise I feel like if we didn't get
distracted with a cow We could have finished this game in an
hour.
Not gonna lie.
I think so too.
Also, if somebody had gone and gotten me towels when they
should have, then...
I did.
No.
I was trapped in the basement.
No, I was trapped in the basement.
I didn't get to...
I was trapped in the basement.
No.
I don't think so.
Anyway, thanks for playing with Vito.
Thank you for my game.
No problem.
That was fun.
That was silly.
how was your first fears to fathom how'd you like it oh
apparently there was like a step that we missed and that's
why it bugged out oh wait but we got the trailer no yeah
yeah but apparently it was an extra step so we weren't not
supposed to like just brute force yeah we did that's why the
car stalled for so long
was the step what was the step like you were there how
you're supposed to oh no i did i unhooked it yeah i did
unhooked it yeah i click out of the game so i'm not lagging
there we go i did there was never a hand break there was
never a break on it that that they told us about matter we
did it two hour play time doesn't it you're supposed to hide
in the trail oh what we're supposed to hide yeah i guess
that one oh no it's fine we i guess it would have been like
we hide a trailer and he walks away and then we unhook it
yeah and then we drive off and remember at the very
beginning it did that like yeah it was like you hide in the
trailer yeah There was that achievement there.
But we did that in the very beginning.
Oh, oops.
But like, it was so much...
Like, there was enough time to do it.
Oh, apparently we're supposed to push the card, too.
What?
He pushed it for us.
Who cares?
Yeah, and then we let him push it for us.
We're just like...
I guess that's why it's like...
We're so...
Oh, my God.
We're so good at this game.
We're too good at it, yeah.
We're too good.
They have another fear.
Like, you play the other fears to fathom, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I've played all of them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you play all of them.
Hey, they should make another multiplayer one.
They should.
He said he didn't want to, but...
Oh, what?
Come on.
Let's see.
It was fun, though.
It was fun with two people.
Yeah.
You should play the other ones.
No, that's fine.
Oh, I will, I'll like join you on stream.
You'll join me?
Okay, all right.
It'll be like multiplayer.
It was fun multiplayer.
Wait, but you already played it, so you know how it goes,
though.
Yeah, I know.
I do have to go, though, because I do have to finish up.
You're like a little, yeah, we're like, it's okay.
It's gonna be, it's, it's, well, you missed a meeting.
Yeah.
Wait, how'd you know?
So in my chat told, Rice said, meeting for this well to be
fair did you tell them it was because we were playing cow
clicker actually i forgot about my meeting oh no was it like
a was it like a densetsu meeting yeah i forgot about it to
be honest i don't understand but also i don't think i would
have made it i think i would have been too busy oh that's
true because of your packing yeah you know you got the
experience you know you you warmed up in this game wait what
time is it it's like It's like midnight for you.
Oh my god.
It's so over for me.
It's like...
Midnight for you.
Hey, you warmed up though.
Wormed up what?
You warmed up for packing.
Because we packed, you know, we packed at the end of the
game.
So you're practically warmed up.
You know how to Tetris things better now.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my YouTube is needing...
Wait, please click your clarity.
This was fun.
I'm gonna go.
Next time when another fear comes out, another multiplayer
fear, it is up.
We'll submit a story.
We should write.
Yeah, we gotta write a story.
We gotta write a story.
We could be the next, we could be the next duo on a road
trip.
Yeah, they have to make.
one about us they have to make it yeah yeah yeah we'll even
voice act for free yes hit us up we'll do it for free put us
in your next game yeah we write our next stream we write a
story that submits to fears of fathom and we're like this is
a true story that happened to us we were playing fears to
fathom and then this happened the game when the paranormal
activities happen okay well actually i gotta go for real but
okay okay yeah go pack go pack yeah thank you for inviting
me thanks donkey thank you bye bye bye don't forget to put
me back on discord normal volume oh yeah yeah yeah i'll do
it right now yeah me too okay you're all disconnected and
then i'll put you at normal yeah i got you okay yay all
right good Thanks!
Bye-bye!
Sorry guys to like skedaddle so quickly, but I do
unfortunately have to like, I do...
I want to get to the meeting a little bit and also I need to
pack.
I don't, I don't want to.
I was, I think tomorrow if I stream it will be like a very
short like one hour yapping session or something something
but I hope you guys had fun.
Thank you so much for the Akka Supas, you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dark Gold.
Thank you, Nexi.
Thank you, Nawa.
Thank you.
Thank you all so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But I got a...
I have still many things to load.
And not a lot of time.
So...
Thanks for the stream.
I'm glad it was it was
Two hour game everybody two Our game Otsumito everyone.
Thank you so much.
Bye.
Thank you for the super chats.
Thank you.
Bye bye bye bye